le monde ça allait à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau stream
les mecs ce soir on est parti pour la
grande finale du bullet championship
2010 9 ans lui dirai mais bon parce que
massa 2010 afin qu est ce que tu veux
c'était pas la fin du monde en 2012 donc
automatiquement en 2019
on est là on est là pour pour la grande
la grande des finales elle allait le
camp penneteau des boulettes à 2019 et
c'est un peu un peu de français dans ce
stream un espagnol
évidemment et j'espère que vous parlez
tous espagnol couramment parce que on va
par l'espagne en jeu toute la soirée
donc on est parti on est parti pour pour
le live et maxime bon on va suivre ça
commence dans trois minutes
donc on va suivre côté maxime alors la
longue liste il est là et on va faire on
peut pas faire folle ou encore je vais
ouvrir le petit chat qui va faire
plaisir dans ma fenêtre et donc ce soir
banque pas de co commentateurs donc sur
un peu plus sur le chat probablement on
va vivre cet événement j'ai envie de
dire dans la bonne humeur et donc les
règles c'est le premier en
en deux sets la ces deux sets gagnants
donc on va se prendre un peu de pub à
offrant la plus pour les speechs usa sas
avait bien les speechs et cette année ça
va être très cool caméra je vais voir à
petit c'est peut-être ça comme ça c'est
mieux
allez on est mieux sur sur la cam
j'ouvre le chat qui n'est pas ouvert le
prends une pub espérant que ça ne fasse
pas tout bogey
non on est bon et donc la petite heure
la pequena finale à je vais pas me faire
bugger à la tweet je raconte ouvre quand
toutes les fenêtres twitch après tant
sûr je suis en sueur pour récupérer le
chat la publicit à la new deal of chess
c'est la publicité là j'ai pu fermer la
publicité là et c'est bon j'ai le chat
et attend alors pourquoi j'ai sa kippa
bien cadré voilà ça c'est bon et ma came
un petit peu à droite c'est ce que quand
tu récupères je récupère des flux de
partout c'est pas évident mais on est
bon on me semble bien il ya la finale ya
le truc à l'échiquier l'échiquier on va
se le mettre on est à la bonne taille
moi je dis on est à la bonne taille
c'est important d'avoir la bonne taille
salut à gaby n'a tort le grand a
salut tonton je vais me récupérer alors
oui mon smartphone je vais me faire lire
est ce que tu peux passer mon smartphone
s'il te plaît smartphones et c'est
gracias mochovce gracias c'est bien ça n
arrive on s'arroge qui comprend tout à
l'envers alors là non mais on a
l'habitude on a l'habitude les amis on a
l'habitude on a l'habitude alors pas
courir je vais te mettre le petit machin
qui fait plaisir
alors faut que je récupère le chat de ce
machin sa tableau de bord mais oui le
chat a envoyé là et on va te faire un
petit host qui as com fr on est royal
oak et 19h faut que je fasse gaffe que
ça que ça démarre pas bavard et c'est
mon cinéma c'est cdma l on est parti on
est parti pour la partie donc pour le
moment il ya 0 0 dans le premier set
j'ai envie de dire première première
partie du premier set alors c'est quoi
ces lieux 4/5 inquiets ces 5
j'ai envie de te lire c'est de la poésie
année c'est de la pompe yanira allez
allons des fonds selon va prendre la 3e
place est des cinq noms il prend allez
on envoie du foie je sais tu quelque
part on va almathea longval mathéou
menacé fourrage cet échec
le joueur français qui est chaude entre
et allez-vous me carélie g5 vas-y mat le
matheux le défonce le irréfléchie
réfléchi tout tranquille tranquille
tranquille on prend et à l'efo défoncé
le roi peut-être un petit coup droit
bien c'est bien joué
le joueur français qui se fait menacer
pion à 2 attention il ya une genre un
genre de synergies fourrage cet échec
vous mesdames le cadre d'un plan b 4 le
premier chip os qui va faire rage suite
non dame qu'adam g 6o le clouage le
contre cheapos assez horrible dame g6
contre clouage et maxime qui pouvait pas
prendre le cavalier c'est extraordinaire
enfin c'est pas non plus extraordinaire
c'est complètement pas extraordinaire
maxime kahn pièce demandant la finale
devon qui va peut-être pouvoir gagner le
premier jeu et faire le premier
mini-break un break qui sera confiée en
meilleur hélas c'est horrible en plus il
peut tout échanger les faits la finale
est perdante leeuwen qui mène 1-0
premier break allait il va falloir des
briques et tout de suite
pour maxime il ya déjà 1 0 1 0 pour pour
le joueur arméniens mais le joueur
français là le joueur français la fougue
à leur rêve ouvrir leur et française
avec qui il va qui s'inspire de la les
kin de notre ami bortnik d'hier porte ni
qui jouera la finale sur les coups de
21h30
21h30 heure française normalement petite
finale 2 2 gla de championship
allez on y va on envoie au centre on lui
balance du f 5 5 dans sa gueule allez
c'est parti
allez maxime on échoue on est chauds
tour c'est 8 on joue le pion ya le petit
poney arié rade petits pions arriérés
petit peu en arrière il va falloir y
aller aller à 5 à 4 on prend l'espace ou
dessin qu'on les change des flux de
placements s'il en a plus besoin et on
va aller le vice est alors attention
c'est du bla fier mais on y arrive
peut-être faire tour f 3 tours a je
crois c'est pas grave
maxime qui est tout en contrôle g6
chasse la dame f5 chasse le cavalier à
léon dégonder gad landais gas même pas
de cavaillon protège latéralement tour 8
hours et sissach arriver il va falloir
taper le pion c2a les maximes on échange
les dames non à les dames c'est cette
ont attaqué quatre lecavalier bouge dame
b si son attaque b21 un coup une menace
il ya peut-être dû cavaler c3 qui rôdent
non pas du tout j'ai kaas groupe g4 est
parti c'est parti prend 2,5 à les boums
le pion b donnant à l'ebu mettions les
deux cavaliers 3 1 qui avait trois c'est
bien joué et fou prend pions prend 15
secondes de plus pour le joueur français
il faut la sueur et celle là on va
débreaké direct à lyon b d'emprise boom
le pion b2 qui tombe d'un proche
trois boucles qu'on sait de qui tombe
attention il ya peut-être si ce qui
tombe à la fin faut pas laisser pas
laisser aux ja damas deux échecs dames 6
dames deux échecs dames aussi sur d'amr
dame provins et sinon la tour qui t'ont
maxime qui dé break d'entrée
allez on le laisse pas s'échapper les
bonnes il est temps de marquer les
points à 11 juin genre de réty j'ai
envie de dire
indian game mais j'ai envie de dire
catalan enfin on ne sait pas ce qu on
joue on ne connaît pas le nom mais c'est
pas grave allait le fou g2 qui va faire
le boulot
le refuge est deux qui va faire le taf
dans cette partie qui a essayé trois
allez un petit fou g5 allez on envoie le
fond angers 5 c'est bien joué les tours
team en arriver au centre rapidement
peut-être d'amsterdam f4 ouais c'est
jouer c'est joué par maxime le fou qui
revient à eux trois ont proposé échange
des foules c'est bien joué peut-être des
changements mais la dame en f4 non
cavaliers à 4 provoque les changes les
fous la foule adam qui est bien placé et
tour d un tour c'est un cas et c'est
simple option bessette presque emprise
non la dame défend aller maximale est
petit allez petit fou prend des cinq on
débarrasse du fou tour d un attention le
fonds a huit qui est pas si mal placé il
tient la baraque
maxime qui a pas réussi à gagner dans un
premier temps il a perdu le fou de cases
blanches il a échangé les bons les bons
levon qui a bien défendu et qui a bien
tenu pour le moment la dame qui arrive
en c3 peut-être du cavalier h5 pour
menacer matin
ouais non cavaliers detroit on revient
vers aux cinq attentats sont une patrie
qui pourrait s'installer sur la grande
diagonale blanche caraïbes et cat
attaque le fou le fou qui vient d'amener
sert pour sam c'est cette année cet
échange des dames peut-être la tour tir
en transe et 7 la case des deux îles
tenu par le cavalier ça peut rentrer ça
peut rentrer à tout moment les amis
attention de pas se prendre un réseau
non je crois qu'il ya rien peut-être la
tour et voilà tout refinancer 7
levon qui veut activer son fou il veut
il veut faire une attaque de maths
malgré tout caisse et s'ils sont à sur
le coup côté maxime
attention attention attention mais ça
paraît pas très dangereux roigé de bien
placer leurs pions aussi ce qui tombe le
cavalier b3 qui tracasse des de
lecavalier qui est mal placé les tours 7
on attaque de partout est ce que le pion
va partir il faut stabiliser qu'un
seconde contre 15 ya deux pions qui sont
partis le pion à eux qui avance qui
essaient cingo rentrer dans la finale
elle est nulle
est ce qu'on flag est ce qu'on flatte
pas pourtant tourcoing 6.5
alors est-ce que ça va être fair-play
les bons qui propose nul maxime qui
acceptent les banquiers sport il veut
pas flag est allé on est reparti rémy an
et demi on a de nouveau les noirs et on
a encore changé puisqu'on a joué des 4,6
pour éventuellement rentrer dans une
défense française alors maxime qui
laisse le pion à vii sur échec est ce
que c'était pas une gaffe
peut-être pas peut-être que oui ça fait
quand même un peu peur surtout en bullet
d'avoir cette colonne h ouverte mais ma
foi si le joueur français réussit à se
développer
ce sera pas forcément où nos problèmes
faut capter des katas j'ai quand même
l'impression que les vents dominent les
bons qui a déjà 10 secondes d'avancé
mais mais mais mais maxime qui se fait
prendre la colonne des fous des cats il
va tenir le pion alors est-ce qu'il va
colmater e5 bien joué ça va aller à
l'essai complètement également quoique
la tour arrivant bessette en premier le
roi a suite qui est pas bien placé ah
ouais mais on récupère ado il va prendre
là on va prendre ces cathos assez bien
joué au hockey
quoique il ya le roi blanc mieux placé
il tape le pion j'ai l'impression que
levon va reprendre l'avantagé alors
attention hein dans ce format c'est le
premier à 6 mai les nuls ne compte pas
c'est pour ça qu'il ya toujours un
partout
la tour c'est un mal placé il échange
ouais il va récupérer le pion aux 3 donc
ça c'est nul théorique
maintenant il ya un petit avantage
autant pour les vols ni un pion plus
maxime qui devrait pouvoir quand même
s'en tirer avec le demi point attention
tout de même aux joueurs armenia
spécialistes spécialiste des finales
comme tous les joueurs à plus de 2800
j'ai envie de dire allez on jette un
petit coup d'oeil sur le chat alors
nivat bon je sais pas les gens me disent
de me calmer et oui les gens sont en
sueur
devant tant d'énergie attention les
finales de pions seront perdantes on
peut pas échanger quand il ya des plombs
doublé allez on y va la tour qui revient
à 6 laurent g7 allait on encaisse son
pion g6 ouais c'est bien joué ça c'est
nul théorique très facile maintenant
proposition nul c'est un match entre
gentleman c'est un match entre gentleman
les points sont partagés mais comme je
vous le disais les nuls ne compte pas
donc il ya toujours un point partout
petit système de londres petit système
de londres pour le joueur français a je
crois on se fait une petite case pour le
fou c'est du commentaire banal mais bon
on est là pour dire des banalités bien
évidemment à 4 allée on envoie le cas
l'hiver à trois têtes on peut rejaillir
verser 4 un jour s'en prendre aux
curieux 5 pourquoi pas b saint calais on
envoie un oui cavalli c4 d'abord le
puits en bessin qui va filer g4 les
bonnes qui attaquent le roi ça peut être
intéressant du lait
les bonnes qui attaquent le roi mais
est-ce qu'il va vraiment attaquer
quelque chose ouais ils attaquent ils
envoient tout maxime qui attaquent
allèles dame
oh la la c'est ça va être ça va être
tendu comme partie est ce que maxime va
réussir à résister aux assauts du joueur
arménien on va voir on va voir fou
détroit bien joué il s'en prend aux
cavaliers v6 on va taper g6 on va taper
h5
pour le moment il n'y a rien sur le roi
lequel valeo 3 qui est impérial il
défend la casse g2 il est bon ce
cavalier
il ya des petites menaces de découverte
peut-être assez malin ce que fait maxime
égale pions âge qui filent et il n'y a
pas de bonnes découvertes pour le moment
c'est dommage on est peut-être plus de
taper h5 mais j'ai peut-être raté
quelque chose
ces joueurs sont quand même une fois
plus fort que moi le pion qui finnois je
crois maintenant attention attention ça
peut être dangereux il peut y avoir du
fou pranger quatre longues rangées de
les cases blanches autour du roi
ça peut être chaud le cavalier qui est
menacée aïe aïe aïe ça fait un peu peur
dame j'ai trois menaces maths en un un
coup de cavaliers non la tour qui défend
à tout âge ils menacent de tourcoing 8
on peut pas si on bouge le cavaly qu'est
ce qui se passe car ces quatre dit et
fait encore pour le moment sa deuxième
cavaliers pros f3 est ce que ça marche
il prend j'ai deux il va prendre trois
la dame emprise cavaliers h1 d'un mach 4
tours h 2 il peut tout défendre encore
tous poils trois tours échec maxime qui
est mal d'alger de il défend tout le
cavalier qui est cloué n'est la dame qui
prend 1,1 dame prend attention cavaliers
encore emprise oh là là ça se joue
cavalier pro 5
ça se joue à rien quand le roi bouge ça
c'est sûr échec
maxime qui s'en sort le cavalière f3
tout est protégé mais la dame en bullet
est très forte
attention les amis ça va être tendu ça
va tu vois là sourire les maximes
allez un petit échec un deuxième échec
un troisième échec échec échec échec
aller purger 5 tours 5
on s'en prend la dame dans tour g4 à ces
menaces et les vols qui fait les échecs
allez encore un échec
allez maxime assez tendu les amis il va
le faire tomber
il va le faire tomber ça y est de 1
allait enfin maxime devants dans ce set
un demi point d'avancé c'est tendu allez
on est de retour les amis on est bien on
mène 2 1 on est dans le match avec les
noirs c'est le moment de faire le break
c'est le moment de faire le break dans
ce match et de prendre
points d'avance aller maxime il est
temps d'y aller il faut faire craquer il
faut faire craquer le mouillé le monde
le moins rare at ararat temps sueur le
mois ratés le cognac a raté tout ce qui
est en lien avec un rare at il faut il
faut tout faire tomber allez une
position un petit peu stratégique le
carélien à f/5 toujours dangereux il
faut deux points d'écart pour gagner le
set bien évidemment le fou qui va
revenir en f1 c'est solide ça maintient
bien
il défend contre le cavalier le plomb
qui arrive en d5 fou prend il va y avoir
du talent b6 échec qui arrive dans le
fou qui courent à sacrifice de dames
positionnelle attention attention de ne
pas trop en faire non plus de ne pas sûr
jouer mais c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'activités il ya beaucoup d'activité
mais ça peut s'éteindre qu'ils étaient
cinq à peut-être tourcoing 8
intermédiaire attention c'était
peut-être impulsif un petit peu ces
sacrifices de dames les banques en train
de stabiliser la position la dame on
sait que c'est dangereux en bullet sa
fédé double attaque
c'est dangereux les pièces et change
petit à petit à voile à la double
attaque au maximum qui peut encore
défendre mais il ya à cette emprise
pareil veut mettre le feu en d6 la tour
qui a attaqué les bons kibaki va
probablement débreaké vous décidez alors
il n'a pas foulé ces chèques il est
cloué à elle est bonne les bonnes
impérial dans cette partie maxime qui a
été un petit peu impulsif sur le
sacrifice de dames mais fou c'est cette
force et il réussit à trouver de
l'activité fous ces cinq cas il ya
peut-être à 5 y arrivent des quatre
aller il va falloir faire des échecs ou
f4 ya ils s'activent les bonnes qui
commence est mal autant magnifique ce
que fait maxime
ils menacent fouet cinq ans y avait tout
reprend des cartes est fou et 5 rater
les bonnes qui est mieux au temps et qui
à la dame qui peut faire des échecs les
bonnes qui en train de craquer les
vannes qui craquent auprès mou tourbe et
si c'est pour jouer va pouvoir faire
trois points 6 sur échec
6 et aller 2 0 de 23 pour maxime premier
break premier break confirmé dans ce
match maxime qui s'envole pour le moment
dans le dans ce premier set 6 en deux
sets gagnants un jeu rappelle 7 en deux
sets gagnants
je rappel c'est en deux sets gagnants
donc si on gagne le premier set on prend
quand même une petite option 3 premier
break confirmé
deux points d'écart les sommes dans le
dur à rognan qui c'est vrai on nous le
rappelle dans le chat avait pris cher
hier face à face à l'ami caroux je crois
un score 25 à 4 quelque chose comme cela
c'est vrai que c'était quand même
beaucoup mais hikaru qui à mon avis va
gagner haut la main face à pornic le
robotnik d'ukraine alors est ce qu'il y
aurait pas un petit d'am dam à 5 qui
traîne un peu depuis tout à l'heure mais
là les vonn a réussi finalement à
s'activer de folie il ya les pièces qui
arrivent sur le roi de maxime maxime qui
laisse le pion qca id4 il veut faire g3
f4 consolider son centre l'aller vonn
qui est beaucoup mieux mais depuis tout
à l'heure maxime sans fin de partie qui
fait la différence face aux joueurs
arménien plus prompte avec sa souris à
10,6 qui marchent pas et un clouage
effectifs fou problème si c'est ce qui a
quelque chose cavaliers maintenant
maxime qui à ce méga fait d'un problème
5 assuré cheikh maxime qui est mal
mais maxime qui fait froncer cats il
joue sur le clouage il va récupérer des
cinq dans le petit jeu de jambes le
petit jeu tactique le flou qui dès
qu'ils contrôlent la case afin qu est-ce
que c'est bien joué de la part de maxime
on peut pas faire dame des six parce
qu'il y avait la tour f 8 ans prise on
peut plus bouger le fouet la maman tu
apprends tout reprend 17 c'est ça va y
aller
allez bonne qui craquent maxime qui
s'envole dans ce set 4 jeux à 1
maxime qui s'envole allez il faut encore
faire la différence faut pas desserrer
l'étau il faut vraiment assuré il faut
gagner ce set
absolument on sait que tout peut arriver
dans ce format un format qui est
beaucoup plus
intéressant à mon humble avis que le que
le format que l'on peut connaître
habituellement sur les speechs s où le
ça joue sur trois heures là il peut y
avoir des retournements des cracks adha
c'est beaucoup plus sympa à suivre
alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir un moment
donné ça à partir ces six on va s'en
prendre aux curieux 4 il va faire
peut-être f3 peut-être un petit coup
table bay 6 voilà on l'eût cru pion à
l'est il faut lui mettre la tête sous
l'eau à les bonnes
il faut il faut pas faux pas faux pas
desserré le samuel eto'o à la dame en
bessette c'est bien placer les bons qui
doit donner un pion maxime qui lui
marche dessus il ne prend pas pour le
moment ils pouvaient pas le prendre
parce qu'il y avait un clouage que je
n'avais pas vu il prend 1 il pas faire
cavalier 5 il est bien maxime cavaliers
b6 ouais mais ce cavalier à ce cavalier
va faire le taf il va faire le tap le
cavalier il bloque le rayonnement de la
dame sur le pion b4 détroit maxime qui
laisse le fou qui va revenir au cices il
s'est un peu désorganisés mais il a un
pion plus d'âme bk que c'est bien joué
calisesi s'y tient le pion à 5 y tient
pions b2 qui a été quatre lecavalier qui
revient qui va faire le taf
ça me prend peut-être du cavalier ou aux
cavaliers c'est 2 le pion b2 qui emprise
ils menacent peut-être x 3 i 6 x 3 pour
le joueur français
ça peut échanger de partout mais rien
n'étant prise ils échangent des changes
échanges b2b menace m'attendais menace
maths en un il ya qu un échec le
deuxième échec et contrôler la dame qui
parlera aux cadres menaces d'amr échec
cavaliers des cartes doria fois 2e
maxime qui voulait faire le beau jeu
mais peut-être que ça passe vers un
échec et d'amener un math maxime qui
prend une grosse option sur ce set
ok ce qu'il est bon maxime qu'est ce
qu'il est bon les bonnes qui n'en peut
plus il a la tête sous l'eau on le voit
la caméra enfin on le voit pas vraiment
mais on voit une tête un petit peu lit
regarde il regarde vers le bas on les
bonnes en sueur 5 1 les bonnes qui est
en train de se faire marcher dessus
le paillasson aronian
mais c'est déjà fait marcher dessus hier
par hikaru et le cauchemar commence
vous écrivez vos ne mérite pas ce
massacre il le mérite
allez on y retourne
maxime qui a l'air très focus sur la
caméra il a vraiment envie de prendre
cette troisième place qui serait mérité
à mon avis d'après ce qu'on a vu dans
les matches quand même les deux joueurs
qui m'ont le plus impressionné jusqu'ici
sont quand même firoud jen a camera même
si nice est fait
s'est fait une frayeur et qui s'est
finalement qualifiée je trouve que fit
rouge a quand même sorti un gros match
c'était d'ailleurs qualifié premier des
qualifiés ferroudja ça sera un client
pour l'année prochaine très clairement
aller le carrier qui repart en f3 est ce
qu'on aurait pu intercale un coup de
hassi je sais pas mais le cavalier qui
est venu faire le taf qui a récupéré le
pion b la position est plus ou moins
égales maxime alors là nul est pas trop
en com vous ai dit les nuls ne compte
pas donc maxime ne peut pas tabler sur 2
nuls pour gagner 7 mais mais mais il
fait le boulot bien joué il fait une
bonne séance formation de structures ce
pion c6 va être dangereux est-ce qu'on
peut prendre prendre pour des deux tours
des six tours points à 6 maxime qui part
pour sa tour ses quatre tours à cette
loi est celle qui va raser les pions il
va raser g7 il va raser h7
mais les bonnes
les bonnes qui envoie b à assez fort
tour à tour qui va venir en b4 peut-être
alors non parce que tours b 4 l'idée
c'était que le pion à partait en même
temps alors qu'est ce qui se passe ici
il prend h
les rois monte ça devrait refaire nul
ici pour acquis par angers 7 à un
univers envoyer le cuir eux il est malin
les bonnes il est mieux autant je vous
cache pas on est mal alors et maxime qui
a tenté le tour prend b2 pour jouer
contre le prêt move et c'est perdu
allez premier débreak de l'ebn lebron
qui revient un petit peu 5 2 il ya
encore de la marge
mais il faut pas aller ses joueurs
arménien s'installer il faut pas laisser
s'installer à mon avis il vaut mieux
faire venir fermer fermi roy fr mire et
fermé le set est fermé le set rapidement
je pense que ce serait quand même
intéressant de fermat 6-2 6-3 j'ai pas
envie de voir leurs meilleurs montages 5
4 il faut faire attention il faut faire
attention il faut faire attention aux
femmes ces sept on va faire j'ai six
grands rock un peu plus faire petit rock
de toute façon les bonnes qui est venu
contrôler la case la case f8 le fou qui
vit à angers 5 maxime pour le moment ça
va
six secondes de retard les van leeuwen
qui a un tirage là les vonn qui a un
tirage qui joue plus vite
il vient de gagner il faut il va pas
falloir laisser l'arménien s'installer
je me répète un petit peu mais on veut
pas voir du grand léjon aujourd'hui on
veut voir du l'éventail est ce
d'ailleurs yaro perez aux commentaires
sur le stream américain on veut de la
taille s à l'est la dante repart en d2
le pion en d4
c'est pas mal quand même pour maxime la
structure de pions des blancs ne leur
permet pas de mettre un jeu offensif sur
le roi noir
maxime qui a bien retourné la position
mais il a consommé du temps il n'a plus
que 22 secondes
après ils semblent jouer plus vite quand
même que le jour armenia mais peut-être
tour deux tours ces deux ans bien joué
j'ai cinq très bien joué et gagne un
pion maxime qui est en train de regagner
autant qu'ils gagnent à la position le
pion bessin qui va tomber dame e3 qui
peut arriver à tout moment sur échec
d'ailleurs il va lui coller un échec
deux échecs trois échecs quatre échecs
c'est le jeu des échecs dames mais voilà
il récupère c'est récupère des deux il
va récupérer à 5
il va pousser il va pousser encore et
dames ces deux ils menacent dame sur
échec c'est imparable maxime qui va
gagner le premier set 6 2 6 2 6 2 sets 0
impérial maxime moins bien autant et
mène déjà 1 7 0 et la partie est donc à
portée
elle est annulée puisque maxime vient de
remporter ce premier set fantastique un
7 0 il a été impérial
il a été facile début de match un peu
difficile et après il a déroulé les vonn
qui a voulu avec l'énergie du désespoir
rester dans le match survivre il est il
est revenu à 6 à 5 2 et puis maxime avec
les noirs qui s'est adapté les vonn qui
a un peu accéléré la cadence et maxime
qui a réussi à à le contrôler je vais
faire une vidéo de la partie de cartes
scène qu'on guérit c'est possible c'est
possible mais je sais par un beaucoup de
vidéos en ce moment on va voir si demain
j'ai un peu de temps peut-être ce sera
fait peut-être pas possible
bah ouais mais c'est vraiment vraiment
une bonne partie et maxime qui remontait
au dessus des 3000 en tout cas maxime
qui est bien dans son match qui est bien
dans son match
donc on voit le tableau alors je vais
peut-être mettre le tableau update et
parce qu'il ya un nouveau tableau qui
est sorti
les nouveaux tableaux qui est sorti ce
que je vais pouvoir éventuellement vous
mettre parce que là du coup on a la pub
américaine je vais récupérer le nouveau
tableau alors je vais récupérer le
nouveau tableau où je vais récupérer les
règles j'ai plutôt vous mettre les
règles je vais récupérer ça vraiment un
joli premier set
c'est en deux sets gagnants à ce match
c'est en deux sets gagnants
a dû récupérer les règles
ah ok dans une petite seconde je vais
preuve j'en profite pour récupérer un
peu voilà les règles sont mises pour le
mans s'est pas encore reparti ça je vous
laisse je laisse prendre connaissance
des règles et c'est déjà reparti avec
maxime qui envoie immédiatement des
quatre donc maxime qui a le service pour
ce deuxième set
j'espérais vraiment 1 2 sets 0 1 et le
prochain match donc qui est prévu à
20h30 20h30 deuxième match je vais en
vidéo deuxième match le match pour la
finale et peut-être prendre 2 à hay joue
à bijoux bea allait peut-être mettre le
pion aux quatre ans le centre a laissé
bien jouer tout à fait d'accord avec moi
non je vais pas me montrer mais
peut-être pendant la pause et dans ma -
peut-être avoir une longue pause
aujourd'hui on va exploser espère avoir
une longue pause parce que maxime il y
en a là il a remporté le premier set 6
jeux à 2 6 jeux à 2 alors d'un prend un
prix dans un prison en prison à
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser pour les
veines se clôt à tour à 7 c'est bien
joué la tour de maxime qui part sur la
7e
et x 3 il s'en prend aux cavaliers
lecavalier qui peut partir en f6 f3
peut-être on monte le royal pions des
trois ans prison objet de reculer est ce
si grave fouet fin il va colmater le
cavalier qui leur passait là-bas le pion
qui va pouvoir rejoindre la structure de
pions leroy qui montant de 3 f 4 5 allée
le pion qui firent peut-être à cavalia 5
c'est pas grave le roi vient en effet en
d3 où il en diagonale par rapport aux
cavaliers n'y a pas d'échec à tout qui
passent derrière quand même c'est un
petit peu stressant cette tour en 1 mais
la tour de maxime honte aussi roi c'est
de tourner si ça fout des six qui va
arriver dans fouet 4 avec l'idée fou g5
c'est bien joué c'est bien vous est fou
j'ai trois halls à la maxime qui me met
tous les coups du tennis 3e 2 les deux
pièces de l'even sont menacés dans le
petit jeu dont petit périmètre
maxime qui a de nouveau été impérial
maxime qui est vraiment au dessus de son
adversaire ce soir il est vraiment au
dessus
il est vraiment au dessus le chien est
très très chaud très chaud très chaud on
sent on sent on sent maxime au dessus on
sent le chien d'accord avec ça avec
cette analyse
c'est vraiment à tout le monde que
maxime a pris le premier set et qui mène
1 0 dans le deuxième a laissé le moment
déjà de bric et de broc est le joueur le
joueur arméniens dans ce deuxième set de
lui mettre de continuer à lui mettre la
tête sous l'eau la tête il a déjà sous
l'eau il est dans la cuvette des wc le
joueur arméniens mais il faut vraiment
lui enfoncer lu en français la tête
allez on prend 1,4
peut-être paraître tour c'est 8 on va
contrôler mal au cours de ces 5 à saint
roch et il va vis et le pion il va
essayer de récupérer c est ce que maxime
va les défendre
non je pense pas il fait un petit échec
pour commencer il gagne h5 à dessein
bien joué de la part de l'even la
tournée plus protégés par le fou à l'est
maxime qui va peut-être envoyé à et
c'est dur là parce que le pion sait il
va pas le laisser falloir le laisser
avancer sa arrive en plus haut car ils
le forcent à prendre de la tour une fois
y en ait une tour devant le fou qui
arrive à pouvoir jouer à quatre il va
sauver pionsat va échanger cavaliers c4
va peut-être arriver fou b4 et sharaf où
j'ai trois échecs qui part de ce côté il
y aura peut-être fou prend ses 7 oui il
y aura foule chef quatre échecs à yao il
n'y a pas de clash sur d8 olala leeuwen
qui se fait encore piégés dans le petit
jeu tactique en fin de partie
il a tous les coups du tennis maxime il
est très fort il est très fort maxime il
a tous les petits il a tous les coups du
tennis tous les coups du tennis
elle est vraiment bon allez bonne qui
n'a pas le niveau il est pas au niveau
maxime qui est simplement au dessus ce
soir
il est simplement au dessus et les bons
qui va et qui va devoir qui va devoir
mon avis incliné mais rien n'est fait
avec ce format de 7 on peut toujours
remonté il faut pas de baisse de régime
faut pas nous laisser y croire à ce
niveau là il faut fermer les matches
mais il faut qu'ils arrivent en c3
ratoureux 5 elle est mal placé à la
presse plus de cases tour f5 on va et ce
qu'on peut lalala l'enfermer si on peut
le faire maxime va trouver comment la
tour qui en d2 avec tellement mal placé
cette tournée on n'arrive pas à la chope
et d'amd deux fous j'ai cinq ça défend
maxime qui perd son temps elle a essayé
d'enfermer la tour il n'y avait pas
moyen de l'enfermer probablement adam
des deux dames e3 c'est peut-être bien
jouer la tour encore sous pression
elle part en h4 c'est pas une casse pour
une tour ça h4 mais elle est en vie elle
a envie d'avoir envie
foucher 4 il veut se débarrasser du
carnaval est repris par le fouquet g37
tour peut-être la dame qui file en âge
six noms tour 3 bien joué mais la tour
ont eu un la tour qui part en a4
incroyable cette tour elle fait le taff
quand même pour pour les bons à les
cavaliers ou quatre pour 8 échéant aux
la découverte incroyable even qui s'en
prend encore une petite et le le couple
cavalier dame qui va finir le job
allez bonne encore une fois qui prend
une tactique de maxime 3 0 ça défile ça
défile à les vols là il va falloir
prendre un temps mort il n'a pas le
droit mais il faut faire quelque chose
parce que là ça va ça va très très très
vite pour l'arménien l'hémorragie n'ai
jamais arrêté à l'est les vonn qui
réussit enfin à placer un petit
sacrifice qui va attaquer ça joue sajou
ou sajoo aller il va falloir résister la
cette partie 3-0 pour le moment les 25
ya plus que la tête sous l'eau mais mais
mais attention attention les joueurs de
ce niveau là les bonnes qui était numéro
2 mondial il faut jamais jamais au grand
jamais les laisser revenir dans un match
il faut vraiment fermé le match fermé la
porte parce qu'ils sont capables de tout
allez fou prend 4 il va y avoir d'amis
chez quatre échecs est la maxime qui est
malin dans cette partie mais il va faire
d'alger 5,9 ou g5 heil a tous reproches
quatre peut-être mais quatre
intermédiaires walla il est pas très
bien maxime le fou est cloué cavaliers
deux bolides est sûr d'apprendre de
yakou prend un f4 aux extraordinaires ya
plus de casse pour le roi incroyable
incroyable maxime qui lui a planté
cavaliers eux deux ils pouvaient pas
prendre le cavalier hausse et les van
leeuwen qui se prend tous les coups là
toute la panoplie de deux coups qui y
passent à leeuwen qui qui est vraiment
en dessous
maxime impressionnant dans ce match elle
est bonne à kiki
qui doit plus en pouvoir il a peut-être
autant désespérer comme jeudi avec ce
format on peut se dire lengagne 2 je
reviens je peux revenir à la marque mais
maxime est tellement impérial tellement
plus fort tactiquement une nouvelle fois
les bonnes mieux dans l'ouverture faut
pas que ça devienne une tendance ont
plus a fait 3-2 de trois parties avec
maxime et mal il réussit à s'en sortir
parce qu'il fait et il fait de la magie
mais attention tout de même si
l'arménien réussi à régler ces petits
problèmes
ces petits problèmes tactiques ça
pourrait ça pourrait tourner
malheureusement pour lui il y arrive
pour le moment pas maxime qui a encore
réussi à s'en sortir
la position reste tendue heures et ce
que maxime va prendre là nul avec les
échecs de cavaliers n'ont pas deux nuls
pas deux nuls tam h3 voilà hall
ah non ça ça va pour les bonnes encore
mais maxime qui réussit un petit peu
échanger des pièces pour 1 kg 5 à radio
4 ya tout y passe le roi qui va venir en
f3 tour f8 auger c'est pour combler
cette ya pas de découvertes qui est
prend des six est sûre qu'elle réussisse
la tour eiffe 7,8 qu'est-ce qu'il est
rapide maxime alors là c'est horrible
pour preuve cette épreuve 7 c au riz
pour l'arménien et les pions passé les
pantalons étaient là il y aurait eu des
pantalons à 5,0 leeuwen leeuwen qui peut
se prendre une roue de une seule roue de
bicyclette mais ça peut faire 6 2 6 0
ça va faire 6 2 6 0 ça peut faire mal
on croirait on croirait rappaz nadal au
premier tour de roland garros
c'est facile premier set on surfe
deuxième set en prend plus n'en
démonstration maxime ça aurait pu être
beau si hier il avait il avait été en
pleine forme pour défendre ses chances
contre bortnik c'est vrai un petit peu
fatigué par sa longue partie en
bundesliga contrarie krishna ce matin
d'ailleurs il en a profité pour battre
une des légendes des échecs les victimes
anne avec les pièces noires maxime qui a
de nouveau un pion plus levona qui a
peut-être un petit peu capituler 5 062
phare il a répondu qu'il avait pris le
score et menaient 1 0
donc en gros là ce qui vient de prendre
ses 6 605 0 pour le moment et
et ça défile clairement pas au niveau
l'arménien clairement pas au niveau
allez tourner un courageux suite il veut
éviter les les fourchettes à une
position avec un pion de plus ce qui est
peut-être pas si facile que ça à
conclure parce que les pièces blanches
sont quand même assez active mais à 14
secondes de plus pour le joueur français
le cavalier blanc qui enfermé alors
peut-être qu'il y avait un truc
ouais peut-être car un truc sur orge et
6 mai les bonnes qui abandonne 6 0 6 2 6
0 massacre massacre absolue alors je
sais pas pourquoi ça joue encore je
comprends pas trop pour moi le match le
match est terminé ici pour moi le match
s'est terminé 2e set c'était c'était un
beau spectacle et j'ai envie de dire
mais c'était quand même peut-être un
petit peu facile pour max yves c'est en
trois sets un nom que je mets du sommet
le match mais après ça se joue en trois
sets
ici il ya deux sets zéro
je ne vois pas trop ce qui se passe si
vous avez des infos sur le live officiel
n'hésitez pas à nous le chat il a joué
pour le feuvre sais pas si c'est
vraiment fun pour les bonnes en tout cas
aïe jouent ils jouent pour le fun ouais
on doit plus ou moins ce format mais
conseil monsieur p soit ice est pas
comment remplir le temps parce que le
prochain match à 21h 20h30
ouais c'est le problème un peu de ce
format soir c'est le problème quand on
fait des tournois de tennis par exemple
on may not before donc le match de dix
cars ou et not before 20h30 il ya 55
minutes à meubler après après à quoi ça
sert de les voir jouer encore une heure
de plus un tel massacre je crois je
trouve pas que ce soit si marrant on va
peut-être jouer un peu contre rennes
chez j'aurais dû aller défier rennes jld
je vais aller défier rennes chez les
amis donc j'espère que ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas être un peu discuté dans
le tchat
et à mon avis le match richard ou
bortnik devrait pas être beaucoup plus
long pas être beaucoup plus longtemps
externe chesnais 1 c'était c'était un
massacre ça a duré 40 minutes
c'est vrai que le match n'était pas
équilibrée
ouais le format est vraiment mieux bah
c'est ce que je disais depuis le déluge
ça fait des années que j'en parle de ce
format alors m je remette les règles
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à follow la
chaîne si vous le souhaitez on est 1025
spectateurs je vais faire une petite
pause ne sais pas ce que vous avez pensé
des commentaires d'ailleurs je sais pas
si ça vous a plu ou pas j'arrive jamais
d'ailleurs à ça si c'est mieux quand
pour tous pour le bullet tout genre
d'événement si c'est mieux quand je suis
en solo quand je suis avec un un autre
commentateur suis pas ce que vous en
pensez d'ailleurs on peut en discuter
parce que c'est mieux d'être à deux ou
seul
j'ai pas si c'est mieux seul ou à deux
du coup un mini tout seul non mais je
sais pas c'est une question pourrait
faire un à un comme on appelle un straw
poll toxiques c'est mieux quand et par
là oui mais peut-être un d'ailleurs je
reste assis finale ckoi deux sets zéro
pour maxime
pourquoi j'ai vécu en russie bof ça
c'est un peu ma vie perso on pourra en
parler plus tard mais combien de temps
10 ans en duo c'est mieux pour les
casteurs et les viewer souvent ouais
donc c'est peut-être me en duo quand
même hein
un + 0 c'est mieux en solo vraiment ma
foi ça dépend vraiment du coup appelons
tous les amis c'est dur à dire en partie
donc je suis sûr que c'est mieux à deux
ans glisse jean sérien en bullet non
plus je regardais cia pas si j'ai pas
des infos maxime qui a gagné juste enfin
de checker un les infos officielles coup
kevin et arenas et 15 jours alors
attends je vais demander parce que là
c'est la fin de la saison lundi
[Musique]
je vais demander
je vais demander je suis en train
d'écrire en fait ce que je lui disais
chaque wii à format best of 5 le
meilleur sur cinq sets c'est pas mieux
kevin basse et le format de la finale en
fait mais là ça aurait pas changer grand
chose à mon ami les bonnes listes des
partis pour se prendre 6 2 6 0 6 2 même
vers la gagne il voulait tuer ce
championship non il a fini troisième
c'est 20h30 la finale cédant 50 minutes
l'une cosy un truc de cinq heures comme
hier en solo enfin tu crois quoi elle
est complètement
[Musique]
montre le chien on verra un million de
fois et puis savez il y en avoir un
petit enfant seb
du coup pas facile car d'avoir un
nouveau petit ça prend du temps là on
voit les jours en interview maxime qui
est heureux d'avoir gagné de 7,0 qui
rigole
[Musique]
est ce que j'ai déjà affronté nakamura
en vrai non je crois pas je crois pas
n'hésitez pas à vous voyez n'oublie pas
que pouvaient follow la chaîne chaise
com fr
quand je regarde un peu si j'ai les
infos comme demandée pour les arénas est
ce qu on me répond temps et j'ai plein
de messages ont du coup j'ai à je vais
pouvoir récupérer ça aussi a refait
pouvoir récupérer
je vais pouvoir récupérer le tableau
donc ça ça va être intéressant
je vais pouvoir récupérer le nouveau
tableau ça ça va être très intéressant
1 m voilà le tableau qui est là
ça va être quand même une information
intéressante pour vous le tableau du
championnat donc on voit on voit un peu
tous les résultats qu'il ya eu une mc à
murat qui a eu un match difficile contre
eux s'ils roulent déjà pour un premier
tour qui s'est qualifié il a joué contre
les bots ou au deuxième tour ensuite il
a battu les bonnes assez facilement 26
28 à 6 et il va retrouver n'a qu'à en
finale et bortnik dans son comté de
tableau qui a limité grid choc cet
ennemi 5 ennemis dans un match tendu ou
gris tout cas bel avantage dans les
ouvertures mais où il a il a perdu
dans le petit jeu de bullet dans les ait
note bortnik qui après a battu maxime 16
12 maxime qui était bien dans le match
jusqu'à la mi temps du match était était
proche mais qui a fini par chuter et
donc porte ni qui affrontera na ka et
dans la petite finale on sait ce qu'on
vient de suivre ensemble à l'instant
c'est maxime vachier lagrave qui l'a
emporté alors est ce que j'ai un peu des
infos pour les arénas en mai crime
hégémonie car aucune info ok donc il ya
pour le moment il n'y a pas d'infos
officielles
je mens si on peut nous lâché une info
officieuse de près de deir n2 en avance
1 qui n'aura aucune valeur n'a qu'à
totalement de surat et c'était chaud
contre firoud déjà
je pense et c'est toi qui gérait les
arénas non c'est pas moi ça reprend
quand les matches leur prochain match à
20h30 la finale et pourquoi pas grâce n
dans le pool parce qu'il n'a pas accepté
l'invitation
ouah machin ce que je vais te sens les
intéressent en anglais donc normalement
si vous voulez allez voir vous allez
voir les interviews sur twitch point tv
slash sytchev donc donc donc n'hésitez
pas à partager aussi un sur sur les
réseaux sociaux
moi je vais mettre un petit mot
peut-être sur twitter tout cas c'est
vraiment c'était vraiment un beau match
que maxime qui a dominé vraiment de la
tête et des épaules
facile il a vraiment été facile na kanak
hacking la fia qui a été tout de même
bon allez je vais mettre un petit un
petit tweet
[Musique]
je met un petit lien je met un petit
lien et je vais mettre une petite petite
photo et je suis rendu je fais un peu de
deux réseaux sociaux perso hop on va
mettre ça comme ça gd l'info officieuse
mais je peux pas en parler
j'ai des infos officieuse mais je peux
rien annoncer encore parce que c'est
trop officieux c'est trop officieux
non je peux rien vous dire les mecs je
peux un brouillard les m je pourrais
peut-être en parler sur ma chaîne perso
mais là sur la chaîne officielle je peux
rien vous dire je peux pas lâcher d'un
coup tu peux pas lâcher d'infos
malheureusement je peux lâcher zéro info
banon mais les arénas je peux pas lâcher
d'infos on dit vendredi prochain on
pourrait peut-être avoir une info a
lâché mais je peux pas lâcher d'un faux
nom mais je peux pas lâcher je lâche pas
d'infos je lâche aucune info là je suis
en train de discuter il ya zéro info a
lâché je peux mais je peux pas dire je
vous lâcherez une info quand j'aurai une
info officielle là je peux pas je peux
pas lâcher d'infos suis en train de
regarder n'y a pas d'infos à la chaîne
alors est-ce que j'ai des infos pour le
pilates championship
je veux pas lâcher l'info c'était propre
arrête maintenant parce que la saison 3
fini ce fini lundi dernier dernier
dernier truc lundi là on me demande de
défi renshaw est salée mais ils sont
encore en interview vallée moi je défie
je défie je défie red rain suivent à
accepter mon défi c'est sur c'est quoi
son pseudo d'ailleurs déjà
ouais allez je le défie je m'en fous il
est en train d'analyser un truc je vais
le défier en bullet j'ai déchiré
non je les défie en 960 je pas le défi
en 960 josephy en standard
andrée ce défi ouvert ça va le faire
super chier à johnny fab dans le truc
ouais bah non il n'y aura pas d'infos
fab pas d'infos aucune info bon je peux
pas lâcher d'infos là dessus on verra on
verra la semaine prochaine jean lacherie
sur ma chaîne perso demain soir à 21h
mais là non est-ce que je peux lâcher
des infos sur le summer league
je vais demander on va voir
on va voir
voilà stupeur les infos
pour les summer league de la prod
châssis qu'on dit qu'il ya des infos qui
vont bientôt sortir minden pas d'infos
non plus j'ai des infos sur rien les
mecs sains parce que chef ben fine gold
away
alors attention ils vont peut-être sur
le stream officiel s'est lâché une info
sur les summer league de las pro-chasse
league
il ya peut-être des infos qui vont être
lâchés sur le stream officiel mais que
j'ai pas non plus donc ce serait des
infos exclu je j'ai pas les infos
personnes me donne les infos dans les
jeux regarder dans un autre chanel est
ce que là il ya des infos non pas
d'infos ici non plus la question était à
la base dans un prochain arena de la
communauté chaise com fr c'est le jeudi
ah ouais c'est ce jeudi cesana
francophone ray
dur à dire du coup mais pas quand je
suis en vacances
enfin car la finale 20 heure française
un bon rennes qui refusent des défis moi
j'en ai marre
ils analysent ils analysent cuadrench
non mais il est parti en pose là moi ce
que je propose c'est court on va faire
des bulles a tenus de nous mêmes il y en
a marre je casse le design tant pis on
va avoir un design complètement cassé et
[Musique]
jean viseur prépare toi toi je jouais
des bullet moi-même coiffage et on va
pas on va pas on va pas attendre des
heures
enfin géré en irak on en voit on joue
contre eux qui super dave 937 à léon le
défonce à l'édile tour g1 on va dire oui
j'ai 4 il va partir le plonger la tâche
prend on prend il prend b2 non il prend
la bomba on va caler flou g5
intermédiaire on va prendre aux fans des
deux serait peut-être plus encaissé g7
[Musique]
ouais on va échanger un peu alors à
faire grand vocal on envoie les mecs on
en voit jean voit de partout dont j'ai
trois tours des trois hommes encaisser
des 6 banques a cédé 6 à l'encaisser eux
quatre ils le voient pas fantastique
fantastic ivoiriens les mecs ils voient
rien n'y voit rien mais il n'est pas de
la côte d'ivoire juste ivoiriens
attention on va faire froid on protège
tous sont là quand ils pion à
envoyez le pion à ça je voulais pas
faire mais j'ai fait on va récupérer le
pion là-bas à lévis et si férois bekaert
on fera échec du coup on va faire ça on
va prendre là et on va à peu près moov
up
ok c'est gagner on y repart et après on
re des filles à hilla décline challenge
c'est quand même hein quoi de décliner
le challenge et wrench évidemment quand
on quand on en a besoin il est plus à
eux seuls taiwo admettre en sueur aie
fait un scan rouge franchement avait que
ça à faire enfin ce nouveau jeu de faire
un stop and go si ça te calmer prendre
là je prends de la lettre le pion à f/5
je reprends ni de reprendre et je vais
perdre un pion mais j'ai peut-être fait
f5 à la fin est-ce que ça touré pas
enfermé il n'as tu pas allumer la
lumière ça te plaît est-ce que ça
tournait pas enfermer est-ce que c'est
pas l'enfer madame est de fous là il va
prendre eux alors fr tour g8 et b6 c'est
chiant
clairement ce chien c'est très
clairement pénible 3,8 qui est déjà il
peut gagner le pion à en force là il le
fait pas on va glisser un échec et on va
venir ici
ok joignant et fitch est obligé de faire
un échec là et je vais prendre ici il ya
plus de pions pour nous autant dire ça
va être dur mais on est mieux au temps
il va falloir être malin gratter un
blessé et l'empêché d'avancer
j'aime pas trop haut
j'avais pas trop ce que je fais bien
ok c'est gagner bien joué alors faire
une petite et puis après on va refaire
une pause voire servaient les choses un
port intéressante qui est important qui
se passe dans le vrai live we refrain
stonewall il est relou ça fait que des
stones où il s'est relooké va prendre là
je suis peut-être un peu planté
alors oui c'est de placer 46 et bim
alors c'est pas fait encore parce que
c'est du bullet les pièces sont pas
forcément encore très bien organisé à
l'est on protège tout on chasse la dame
une fois on chasse la dame deux fois on
chasse le cavalier on chasse la dame
encore on encaisse le cavalier protège
le roi en échange les dames et il
abandonne on va retourner sur le tchat
je vais remettre je vais voir ce qui se
passe sur le truc officiel iam arrouays
on va aller ça mais on va voir un petit
peu ce qu'ils racontent on sait pas ce
qu'ils racontent en ayant signé dans une
interview comme on rigole et qu'on va
reparler un peu ensemble c'est en trois
sets gagnants la finale 1 ouais
ça va être quand même un peu la qualité
du stream j'ai presque envie de
résultats de mv l'harmonie ahmad le
remettent du coup à les résultats il a
gagné deux sets zéro
donc c'est sympa assez petit bullet
finale n'a réservé aucun suspense et là
ça on va voir j'espère quand même sur un
peu de suspense ouais c'est sympa ces
petits bullet histoire de meubler un
petit peu on les a bien on l'a bien
défoncé le mec là on lui a mis à nu amis
on a tout gagné l'an villette on a tout
gagné
pari de remonter un peu le niveau ça
permet d'élever un peu le débat on a
élevé le débat avec ses bulles est
historique c'est un tueur gagné haut la
main sur aronian n'ont pas vraiment
c'est plutôt l'inversé habituellement
mais dans cette cadence oui faut s est
pour la tour marché pas non je sais plus
ce que l'on appelle même plus des partis
l'un malheureusement ça allait vite et
du coup je me rappelle pas forcément de
tout ce qui s'est passé dans les parties
en bullet mais ça a suffi pour gagner
les 3 c'est tout ce qu'on souhaitait
faire quelques pourrait apprendre le
bullet aronian de wan'an je pense plutôt
lui qui peut m'apprendre un honnêtement
aronian qu'il n'y fois plus fort que moi
en bullet
aussi il est plus fort que moi dans tout
les cadences il est vraiment très bon
levon ça rime
il est vraiment très bon les bons je me
souviens de la demi finale perdue par
max contre aronian way en coupe du monde
et puis l'avait perdue a perdu d'autres
d'autres parties importantes face à face
à levon aronian donc
dans une victoire assez logique et assez
tranquille de notre nvn nationale c'est
dommage de ne pas avoir vu et vl fil
rouge avec un nouvel en forme et un
parce que bon face à ce qu'il a perdu
contre vu qu'il a perdu contre bortnik
et qu'à mon avis si rouges avaient quand
même à plus fort que portiques on
imagine sur et can perdue mais voir
élevé à la 100 % face à peer ou déjà ça
aurait été intéressant
je pense qu'elle veut elle aurait perdu
compte firoud diarrhée mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils auront déjà bientôt
dans toute les cadences
il va être dur à prendre
ouais je suis d'accord il joue maxime
sas a joué plus plus du bullet il joue
plus aux échecs que les autres non mais
les joueurs les plus complets ses filles
rouges à aynac à irujo anacarde scène
ces trois là ils font ils font les deux
ans il réussit sa joueuse d'échecs et à
faire les tricks les tricks du bullet en
fait ils ont vraiment toute la panoplie
du joueur du joueur de bullet et c'est
vrai qu'en fait à quand on regarde le
tableau par exemple un joueur comme
portes qui claquent est en finale on
peut dire qu'il a que les tricks aronian
mvl ils ont que les échecs fédérer
federico perez ponsa il est assez
complet aussi d'ailleurs celui que
maxime a battu au premier tour après
moins fort mais il était complet il
avait et les échecs et les tricks
donc il y avait des joueurs complets
quand même les joueurs complets c'était
ki-duk on peut dire naka à onna cas les
joueurs complets n'a qu'à fuir ou dja et
perez pour ça donc ça c'est les joueurs
complets les joueurs plus échec c'était
nv elle les bonnes banques arias qui
n'avaient pas de connexion donc on va
pas le comté et great chioukhs et les
joueurs bullet bullet
y'avait que bortnik en fait ici qui
était vraiment qu'ils étaient vraiment
mono style et on aurait pu avoir le
pingouin aussi qui aurait pu se
qualifier qui était pas loin donc on
aurait pu avoir de vrais spécialistes
mais je compte pas je compte pas perez
pont de 5 entre comme un joueur vu la
bulle est pour ceux qui ont vu le quart
de finale hier je les trouvais perez
pour nous c'est vraiment très très
solide dans les dents dans le milieu de
jeu il connaissait bien ses schémas il
jouait pas mal
il était bon en typo il était vraiment
complet après ça ça n'a pas suffi contre
maxime mais c'est un joueur c'est un
match qui s'est joué au but en or donc
ça ça aurait pu ça aurait pu tourner
d'un côté ou de l'autre
ouais c'est vrai been cause que maxime
il est un peu plus complet que que que
notre ami que notre ami les vonn savait
qu'ils étaient un peu plus complet mais
dans les tricks
il était quand même en dessous d'eux
de bord unique dans le petit jeu des
prêts moula en fin de partie bortnik
était quand même
il était quand même au dessus de maxime
il était vraiment forme
ouais le pingouin qui est bon donc le
prochain match qui doit de redémarrer
dans une demi heure
est-ce qu'on peut suivre et ce que je
peux déjà suivent naka s'il est connecté
et je n'arrive pas toujours à faire de
faux l'eau en fait je peux follow
bortnik je vais follow bortnik histoire
d'être sûr de rien rater je met un petit
coup les règles il sort que vous ayez le
règle du match n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs
à un polo à mettre le petit follow le
petit choeur sur la chaîne chaise comme
il va y avoir beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'événements et beaucoup de ce crime
cette année avec les speech est assez
grand prix fille la coupe du monde fidh
il va y avoir beaucoup d'événements donc
n'hésitez pas à mettre le petit coeur
pour ne pas les rater et merci à tous
d'être aussi nombreux ce soir pour cet
événement pour cette finale
donc un grand merci d'être si nombreux à
suivre la finale qui débutent dans 30
minutes en espérant
qu'on ait un beau spectacle tout de même
même si bortnik semble sans landes sous
sur le papier on sait jamais on ne sait
jamais ça a démarré dans 25 minutes
ça démarrait dans 25 minutes parce qu'il
ya des questions quoi dans le chat je
pense pas ça te prendre petite
respiration tout en vous lisant
je regarde un peu ce qui s'est passé sur
les autres sports je crois que clermont
a battu le racing a n'ont même pas eu
match nul finalement incroyable
incroyable
ça fait trente et un 31 incroyable
clermont qui a pas réussi à battre le
racing heures qui qui dominait largement
c'est étonnant maintenant raté la
pénalité de la gagne à la dernière
seconde je vois ça je vois ça c'est
étonnant
pourquoi il ya tant de différences au
niveau dans bullet on dirait que c'est
plus resserrée en cadence lente nous
demande j baba bâ en fait c'est assez
une raison assez simple et
compréhensible ces camps en cadence
longue en fait il ya plus deux nuls donc
forcément ça resserre ça resserre les
niveaux en fait ce que six sur dix
partis il ya huit nuls et deux victoires
tu auras l'impression que le mec il a
gagné que six que que 6,4 et donc tu as
l'impression que c'est plus serré alors
quand bullet ça aurait peut-être fait
cette victoire à troyes où cette
victoire 7 à 2 et une nulle sans effet
cet ennemi deux ennemis donc en fait dès
que tu enlèves là nul ça forcément ça ça
ce mec mécaniquement les différences de
scores sont plus grandes
c'est assez logique en réalité qu'elles
sont ici l'ouverture privilégie en
bullet ça dépend ça dépend des joueurs
là vraiment mais c'est de jouer des
systèmes plus que des ouvertures parce
qu'il faut enchaîner les coups vite donc
gérer que c'est plus des systèmes
votre avis est ce qu'on peut voir du
simple ça doit j'espère que ce sera pas
un massacre à 3,7 0,1
oui car oui il peut jouer la ruine il a
joué d'ailleurs hier à plusieurs
reprises donc il peut il peut y avoir
des ruines des russes peuvent partir la
voix comme système à part londres
système de long d'un système de long le
stonewall tu peux jouer des airs et
idées d'attac astérienne tu peux jouer
des méthodes ruiz des systèmes
hippopotames tu peux jouer des systèmes
co le fameux il peut faire des systèmes
colle aussi n'a qu'à t'en as pas mal
tu as le choix
exactement ce que dit renaud su contrer
est longue je me fais je me fais
exploser je tiendrai un toit plus qu en
bullet tu avais plus de temps de
réflexion
c'est pareil au niveau le temps nivelles
le talent va justement c'est un des
arguments de ben laden quand ils étaient
mieux les parties rapides où les blitz
parce que tu voyais plus le talent est
élu niveau de jeu ce que t'as pas le
temps d'organiser mais en fait la
vitesse de calcul c'est quand même ce
qui fait la différence aux échecs
après tout dépend la vision de tam et si
tu penses en esprit compétition le
rapide c'est plus tu as plus les joueurs
doués quoi s'il se départagent
officiellement on peut imaginer 71 69
juste pour le premier set façon mahut
isner serait possible hein ça me chante
là ce serait théoriquement possible un
façon s'ils font ce format là on verra
bien un jour 1 20 18 ans et obliger un
si ce format est utilisé dans les
futures compétitions mécaniquement on
aura des résultats spéciaux
c'est une évidence
il ya quand même participant ce soir
alors il reste plus que la finale ce
soir n'ont plus que deux il a perdu
combien nva lendl a gagné là il a gagné
6 2 6 0 et pour les résultats d'hier je
les remets voilà les résultats d'hier
que tu as à l'écran ça va commencer dans
20 minutes
j'ai mis au kawa le follow donc on n'est
sûr de rien rater
on est sur deux d'avoir d'avoir le
direct un petit peu de huit petites
minutes de patience à avoir ils ont raté
e égal m6 je sois pas raté grand chose
on va voir moi je vois bien un score du
genre 6-2 6-3 6-1 quelque chose comme ça
mais j'espère que que portiques
réussissent à prendre un set
et qui sait si gagne 1,7 après tout peut
arriver un naka qui était pas non plus
impressionnant impressionnant hier bon
il a de la marge mais il peut être un
peu en dilettante donc on peut on peut
qui sait avoir une petite surprise en
tout cas un match plus serré qu'on
l'attend c'est possible
pas probable mais possible
en tout cas ça durera pas ça durera pas
jusqu'à minuit et demi comme hier
il peut avoir envie d'humilier son
adversaire aussi et lui faire mal je
pense qu'on a caressé faire un gros
début de match avec ce format pour
prendre le premier set après on verra
la caf stocks qui a soumis l'idée de
cette fois c'est moi qui ai soumis cette
idée de cette way cette idée a été
soumise par ma propre personne et je
trouve que c'est beaucoup plus marrant
que je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
marrant que les matches à rallonge comme
celui qu'on a vécu hier entre les vols
la même avec mpl on a envie qui
finissent le match c'était plus amusant
ah non c'est pas mal franchement c'est
pas mal faut le savoir
c'est écrit c'est vérifiable que c'est
moi qui l'ait qu'il est miss salut
germinal salut germain ça va la forme
germain qu'est ce qu'on a sur le mans
n'a rien on va laisser le tableau c'est
quand même ce qui est intéressant là je
trouve avant le avant le match ça débute
dans 15 minutes
préparez votre dîner préparé votre petit
plateau repas prenez vous si vous le
souhaitez une petite bière sans alcool
histoire de suivre le match en toute
décontraction
argument un petit peu les petits et
petits petite entrée après le match je
mange et les merguez vegan peut-être je
sais pas combien de temps ça a duré on
sait pas quand même temps ça a duré 1
mais c'est en trois sets gagnants
à mon avis ça a été un massacre à massac
ça veut dire non nenê se demander ce
qu'un alors allez on va voir le chat qui
est ce qu'un massacre ses longues lent
je comprends le gros massacre massacre
en france massacre une boucherie
tu penses seloncourt cours voilà c'est
ça un massacre toi si tu viens avec une
tronçonneuse tu découpes le mec parce
que je n'y ai pas ce que c'est une
tronçonneuse alors une tronçonneuse
imagine tu as un arbre par an les
bûcherons il avait une hache tu as you
père lâche maintenant tronçonneuse cc
truc tu allumes comme ça ouais donc à ça
être massacre à la tronçonneuse à mon
avis à mon avis oui mais après on sais
pas peut-être qu'il va y avoir une
surprise on espère qu'ils aient un peu
de surprises mais normalement sur le
papier c'est un match si tu es ce un
match de tennis tu fais pas un point là
c'est 6 0 6 1 6 2 tu vas tu dis que j'ai
fait un bon match nul à des prix que je
sois tu es content
à mon avis ça va être ça va être temps
ça ça va être ça pas tendu c'était tendu
pour eux pour bortnik merci alexandre
junior qui me kim qui me félicitent pour
la performance et les 2007 mario tessier
paris 6 0 6 0 6 1 en 48 ouais c'était
champions par le match a duré 43 minutes
est-ce que je jouais l'accord bull est
gelée battu d'ailleurs une fois en
bullet naka tension 1 j'en ai les coller
une petite anna k en bullet
donc
donc donc
ton ami kevin il faut qu a le niveau
pour comprendre ce qu'il va se passer
comment tu commandes pour vulgariser à
bas il faut écouter mes commentaires en
général cool j'ai fait un tas à peu près
sur youtube 750 eur 2,2 contenu donc ça
va tu peux tu as le temps quoi c'est une
série netflix tu vois tu tu te poses tu
reviens dans deux mois n'aura pas vu
toutes les vidéos et je les bats tu
oublies de ceux-ci ouais on dit que
regarder le trim us alors qu'est ce qui
se passe sur le stream us
est ce que l'an prochain porte ni sera
qualifié d'office à c'est pas moi qui
décide ça j'en sais rien
quoi ya pas l'image et sans savoir
l'image mais bon qu'est ce qui se passe
sur le stream officiel
ils me font peur sur le stream officiel
bon le match n'a pas commencé c'est sûr
[Musique]
ça va prendre combien de temps ça
reprend dix minutes et à une meuf le
flou je suis classé combien en file pour
les parties donc 2003 mais j'ai arrêté à
jouer de jouer très tôt j'ai arrêté à 17
ans non ils remontent les parties d'hier
web une cause pas songé un flou sur
bortnik normalement on peut pas les
rater allez je vais jouer grand big boss
les magnets ans suri les 1100 il est
même pas devant l'ordi peut-être ayant
sûr ça fait une demi heure qu'il a mis
le défi mais je vais le troll si la
porte et qu'il propose un défi je refuse
donc tu devais saisir ta chance pour
avoir l'honneur de jouer contre moi tu
devais être devant ton ordinateur
je vais le troll live à thé coeur et il
va savoir après quand il va revenir
qu'il avait qui il avait joué contre moi
oh non j'ai gagné la partie car même
s'ils gagnent 0 voulait que je défie
robert s non ça a l'air d'être là est
pour opérait ce je le vois ils ont l'air
tellement triste là sur le site sur le
truc officiel je suis en train de les
voir c'est une conversation robert s il
essaye de dire un truc
franchement je sens au visage il en
galère je veux pas je veux pas le mettre
dans le mal en fait à jeu sans galère
robert s tu sens qu'il veut donner son
avis mais que mes krejci rebondit pas
trop quoi je veux pas le mettre dans le
dur
je vais le mettre dans le dur on dit
baies séchées en fait l'heure maintenant
elle est utile et bien la fin il est
parfait la l'échiquier
alors ça commence dans dix mille par mes
grands big boss et d'attention quand il
a un peu joué avec ct sont des filles il
va suaire par michel pas qui on peut
défier franchement peut défier krikor
est quand même à peut-être accepter non
il accepte pas les challenge doit tant
sur avec les gens qui font des challenge
tout le temps comme moi et du coup il
peut plus accepter le challenge bras
c'est dommage je sais pas qui je peux
troll je peux trop la mère en lui
proposant un défi c'est une consécration
pour amr de recevoir un défi de ma part
m
ils ont atteint l'île en sueur c'est
clairement une ancien rameur il a reçu
on défile en sueur et la suède si je
peux si je peux je des pièces à les mecs
ce défi robert s
non c'est marrant il passe à autre chose
mais j'ai des pièces palmarès de kevin g
défi robert s mais ils veulent pas jouer
ça sent ça sent il a peur au psg trop
mis en gage et romy en ps
oui je pense pas que
chez pai pas se passer un truc de match
parce qu'il faut bien mettre qui me
défends kim défi non mais c'est pas
c'est pas un mec klimt roll robert xl
soit tout à fait je sais pas qui on peut
troll en fait je suis la personne qui
joue de bras fettouhi commandant on est
on a on a on a affaire à des gens qui
vont pas accepter de défi quoi
franchement je condé mais qui n'ont pas
accepté le défi
bon je défie gris tchouk haye il accepte
pas les défis voyons galère
honnêtement galère
ça démarre bientôt toute façon ça et
maman six minutes on a un peu récupéré
jeu statique et pourquoi n'y a pas
d'image mais c'est une image là il ya le
tableau un puzzle rage que j'aime pas
les peser à l'heure h
trevor perso qui est bon c'est chiant
faut changer de design et tout fait
j'aime pas trop en fait c'est bien pour
les autres en fait peser le rush des
ricard où il a mis tout le monde en
sueur il s'en foutait un peu d'ordre à
chaussy il a fait tuer tout le monde
puis montez par un échiquier mais bon
face et le tableau quoi déjà pas mal
moi
non mais je peux pas faire cinq ans non
mais bon fins d'y jouer quand j'étais
gamin ça ces jeux là maintenant c'est un
peu lourd
fois c'est plus de parties longues fidh
parce que j'aime pas en fait tu avais ce
que tu live demain soir où tu es en
vacances non je live demain soir je suis
en vacances samedi prochain mais je
ferai des live un de mes vacances mais
bon pas avec des échiquiers on verra
j'ai prévu de faire un des lives de mes
vacances avec une avec une perche telle
fille et de faire des live comme ça
avant évidemment et 90% des gens qui n'y
a que pour un des échecs parce que comme
dirait vlad nous sommes des animaux de
zoo donc évidemment tu te poses des
chèques n'intéresse plus personne qui
est un genre de d'un genre d'animal 2 oh
combien voire à la foire tu vois ce
genre est une merde qui joue mais bon
pour les gens qui ont envie qu'ils ont
envie de discuter tout ça tu as aidé des
petits live comme ça pour les gens qui
ne prennent pas pour un animal deux eaux
du coup comme ça on pourra faire la
différence sur le tchat
on pourra noter les pseudo
savez quoi ton projet avec va assez long
à faire j'ai pas faut que je revoie
blindés tout pas évident non vaccinés tu
peux faire le singe je veux essayer
parce que j'aime bien le crazy house
tactiquement c'est intéressant je trouve
non en fait non bah je peux y jouer
enfin nous ont fait complètement fait de
néma d'huîtres inc à reconnaître qu'on
pourra jeter banide ellison 40 rue
caruana car c'est la préférence
caruana sans aucun doute quand est-ce le
fait des chèques à quatre avec fabas
j'ai pas trop aimé non plus en fait 3
les déchets k4 de base mais le vent il
serait une bonne idée que favre face
ouest est marrant c'est marrant il rage
toujours quand il est vrai que celui
contre lui c'est drôle vous apprenez
réellement les parties pour les vôtres
je comprends pas trop ta question pied
trog 51 quelle variante j'aime bien
[Musique]
non mais en fait je suis pas assidus à
aucune variante messieurs fait soit en
réalité parce que je trouve que c'est
des jeux mineurs que personne y jouer du
coup tu vois comme je passe déjà ma ma
journée à jouer aux échecs à donner des
cours à machin honnêtement tu vois je
n'ai pas envie de me remettre devant un
échiquier pour pour rejouer peut-être le
960 ce que ouais le 964 cyril parce que
semer ses des échecs fins lte est libre
et d'échecs 960 en réalité mais
[Musique]
mais bon ouais je suis pas fan de toutes
ses variantes honnêtement je préfère
jouer peut-être carrément autre chose
dans ces cas
mais chez christophe capable qataris
m'intéresse vraiment pas en faites-vous
pour nettement pour des parties
personnel tu apprends des parties de
grands maîtres vous l'ouverture
seulement un bien sûr tu apprends des
parties de grand maître et où un
forcément tu connais plein de partie en
fait qui a dans ses cours tu apprends à
être dans l'esprit pas vraiment which
switch pas votre cas pour bortnik non
mais le 966 étaient plus populaires
j'adorerais way
c'est sympa ça je suis d'accord bon là
ça va partir dans une minute normalement
en quasi stream du fiff alors mais tu
sais j'ai vraiment pas de fin si tu vois
mes journées longues de kmg vraiment pas
de temps honnêtement c'est juste dingue
en fait mon emploi du temps est juste
dingue mais juste vraiment vraiment
dingue
et en plus quand je joue à des jeux
j'aime bien try hard en fait et il aime
bien jouer à des jeux qui sont un peu
populaires qui sont joués par part entre
guillemets beaucoup de monde j'ai perdu
faut supporter ni congelé remis donc
[Musique]
donc tu vois si je travaillais dans le
jeu tu as j'aurais pu try harder stones
ou ce genre de choses
éventuellement mais tu vois j'ai pas 80
heures par semaine à investir et jouer
quatre heures par semaine ça m'intéresse
pas en fait si c'est pour décorer être
nul ça m'intéresse pas pas trop en fait
rapidement ça ça m'énerve
est-ce que je pense que je pourrais être
gm si je le voulais alors aujourd'hui je
ne sais pas si ce serait possible mais
quand j'avais 17 18 ans si j'avais voulu
oui sûrement mais j'ai pas voulu en fait
du coup la question ne se pose même pas
bon
mondial gr en ressentant des tournois
officiels tu fais des normes machin
allez c'est parti
c'est parti les amis allez trève de
plaisanterie donc on regarde le match
côté alexandre bortnikov le joueur
ukrainien qui a wider dans ce match est
donc on regarde son côté parce que on va
être un petit peu pour lui alors on
n'est pas pour lui on préfère pas
bortnik à hikaru loin là c'est juste
qu'on veut voir un match serré premier
set on espère que pornic rentrent bien
dans le match
histoire qu'on ait un vrai du alors
bortnik qui souffrent un petit peu dans
l'ouverture qui a mis du temps à jouer
il a déjà eu secondes de retard mais il
a une position jouable même si hikaru à
la paire de fou donc ils allaient de fou
mais bortnik qui va réussir à west
gratuit rideau les dix réussit
inscriptions isolé non c'était pas
terrible mais il a le temps de faire des
4 puis on prend qui apprend qu'elle
prend fou prend tour d un il va se faire
clouer bortnik et déjà foutu il va être
obligé de reculer le fou 20 secondes de
retard un pion de retarder 5 s'est fait
puzzle rhj est d'entrée oprea fisc
épreuve trois échecs intermédiaire boo
boo boo fait six cavaliers g3 ou
cavaliers qui va être dangereux il
récupère quand même le pion bortnik est
pas si mal qui a réussi à se mirent
d'accueil car vous met il à 20 secondes
de moins 20 secondes de moins facile car
nous normalement c'est synonyme de
défaite ada et caron qui a le pion passé
en d5 la meilleure structure de pions
l'avantagé à la pendule le pion à vii
qui tombe on va voir si bortnik réussi
ou bortnik qui a bien trouvé ton g8 le
g5 rapide mais hikaru qui va quand même
encaissé le pion en douceur asséné un
jeu de la partie car oui car au café
froid et froid sur mon bloc l'acadien ii
les carreaux qui va encaisser le curage
5 le pion à chaque pour icare ou le pion
à 2 pour boeing portent ni qui est bon
mais porte qui a plus que quatre
secondes contre 30 euros là là là il
aura pas le temps
hikaru qui va déjà marqué le premier
point il y aurait il utilise la moitié
du temps c'est un massacre est ce que ça
laisse présager de ce qu'on va voir
je ne sais pas encore espérons bortnik
renverse rapidement la vapeur il
faudrait pas que ça tourne à la
correctionnelle qui est porte ni kiowa
laisse assez bien joué
il envoie une qualité ils attaquent
directement donne du matériel il
s'active il joue plus vite dans cette
partie avec les blancs on l'avait déjà
vu dans les matches précédents il avait
du mal avec
les noirs à sortir de l'ouverture c'est
exactement la même chose face à hikaru
petit roquet ce que le plomb le zinc va
tomber non pas pour le moment il y avait
calé j'ai quatre îles mais qu'elle va
les manger sain qui l'attaquent enfilade
il récupère la tour la dame dit car ou
est mal placée elle va peut-être partir
vers huit cavaliers g4 ils contre
attaquent la dame en âge de comprendre
ça tu es proche d'eux foudroyé fuite non
ils gardent les dames sur l'échiquier
c'est peut-être un peu dangereux il ya
une patrie sur le roi il prend le cas
trois quatre ans j'ai quatre fous j'ai
ici c'est chaud portiques à 15 secondes
de retard ricard ou qui jouent vraiment
très vite aujourd'hui des cinq des
quatre sa part cavaliers à 4 le cavalier
un peu mal placé mais c'est pas si grave
d'en prendre trois intermédiaires à
gênant mika rookie a peut-être raté un
pion toujours très secondes avant de
pourris car ou 40 qui menace le clan à 2
va peut-être des trois dames m6 pour
s'introduire sur case noire s'est jouée
par ikea ou leroy qui montrent la dame
qui file en un an tout aussi ce tour
aussi ça l'est peut-être un échec bien
vu de la part de portes qui couvre la
casse ces trois le couple dame cavaliers
qui va attaquer le roi noir quel droit
le plus faible c'est probablement le roi
dit cas où le cavalier qui va arriver
non c'est la dame qui vit en c6 d'amagne
couvre des cadrages et un la dame qui a
peut-être passé à 5 n'est pas de ce côté
là la dame qui revit angers cet ancien
ghetto portée qu'il ya bien bien bien
retourner la situation au c'est bien
joué et karuru j'essaie de bien jouer
il couvre tous bords qui ramasse les
pions toujours dix secondes de retard
pour le joueur ukrainien dame 17 à me
ranger 4 et 15 ans qui retourne un peu
le truc dames la dame qui va repartir
vers son goût il attaquait de damages
cinq échecs s'est jouée en pré boufous
g7 aussi fou qu'on des quatre il ya plus
le cavalier ya 14 secondes de retard
bortnik qui avait été très rapide face
aux autres joueurs mais raphaël carbou
c'est une autre limonade et la limonade
une limonade goût sucré limonade vous
sucrer limonade
goût acide en fait l'hymne a trait à 6 2
0 pour hikaru parti qui a montré de plus
belles choses dans le milieu de jeu dans
cette partie mais il a été un petit peu
lent hikaru donc il fait le premier
break dans ce match mais je le rappelle
c'est en trois sets gagnants rien n'est
fait la tour de borny qui part vers g5
attention portée qu'ils aiment manière
un petit peu original mais ça peut
peut-être rapporté des dividendes dans
ce match nul est à 3 b 4040 qui prépare
de chasser le cavalier va sûrement
échanger les dames n'ont ils préparent
des cadres des quatre qui va partir des
quatre il parle du cavalier qui va
partir qui part en b3 au la fourchette
fourchette fourchette pour bortnik il
cas où tout prend 7 mai sur deux lames
français cet os il y avait la tour j'ai
cinq ans prise mais a quand même une
calèche qui tombent ils se rendent coup
pour coup hikaru qui avait pas tout vu
mais la tour penchée secte est mal
placée elle revient en jeu mais
malheureusement pour portique l'option b
5 et fort ils filent vers b6 3f deux
tours b 8 au camp des systèmes achat
alors deux pions pour la qualité qu'est
ce que ça vaut ça doit être mieux pour
les blancs attention tout de même
attention tout de même à peut-être y
avoir foule détroit où il va casser la
structure afu pranger 6 ça devrait faire
un nul probablement mais ça va être plus
facile à jouer pour hikaru proposition
de nul de la part de porte ni qui est
acceptée ricard ou qui a pas voulu faire
parler les 10 secondes de différence
comme je vous l'avais déjà dit dans le
premier match là nul ne compte pas et ça
va y aller aller hikaru qui va envoyer h
4 h 55 il ya eu 5 et dans ses portes et
qui a les blancs je me mélange un peu
les pinceaux le pion qui n'est en d5
attention peut-être un petit coup de
fouet si ce n'est un b3 coupe les
oreilles du cavalier b6 le pion qui
parent à carton va déstabiliser le
cavalier carrie qui va revenir vers b2c
quatre peut-être fou trembler 6 qui va
claquer g3 pour le moment c'est un jeu
de manoeuvre bortnik qui semble être
enfin rentré dans son match il a pu un
petit peu jauger la puissance de hikaru
qui a envoyé 2 3 kamehameha en début de
match mais finalement bortnik qui
réussit à tenir
allez là sa part 4 et au moment où je
dis ça il suffisait de le dire pour que
la torah 1 reste en prise et qu'elle
tombe mais bortnik qui s'active un peu
alors est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose rock
à épron dessins qu'il ya des pièces
emprise de partout il récupéra bortnik
est pas si mal que ça ou si ou pas il ya
beaucoup d'échangés a beaucoup de choses
qui se passent matériellement on en est
où il ya un pion pour la qualité mais
les tours sont bien placés beaucoup de
colo nouvelle fonction qui arrive en c4
à tour qui va aller en d2 tour des trois
tours des huit peut-être pour des deux
tours et ficales pions f qui peut être
en danger
voir comment ça se passait autour des
huit tours 8 allait-on ces deux échanges
une paire de tours c'est toujours bien
joué mais y'a un pion qui tondent ni
carlo qui va aller essayer de faire
parler son pion ses pions de ce côté là
les deux pions passé face aux cavaliers
c'est bien joué fou dessin qui font
cavalier prise prise ses trois cahiers
français 3 pas possible retour à troyes
le cavalier qui revient tant bien que
mal pour protéger ses deux bêtes obligé
d'envoyer deux cavaliers et les trois
pions pas scellier ne vont rien faire à
1 dames et c'est fini hikaru hikaru qui
prend qui prend le large 3 0 pour icare
où il ya en démonstration mais bortnik
qui semble un peu rentré dans le match
avec ce format de 7 évidemment c'est
c'est un peu moins pénalisant de faire
un très beau mais le match même s'il
perd le premier set 6-1 voire même 6,06
réussi à jauger car oui la presse m ça
pourrait être plus serré par la suite
allez ça va échanger
on va y aller ça avait changé en vingt
cinq ans ont accueilli dans le chat que
ça fait cher et ouais ça fait ça fait
cher parce que parce qu'ils car
aujourd'hui semble plus fort qu'hier il
a été un peu mis en difficulté par
firouz jamais il semble en forme
il semble en forme aujourd'hui car où
c'est sûr qu'il prend pas ça à la légère
c'est une finale c'est quand même un
titre honorifique lui qui se vante
d'être le meilleur joueur en bullet sur
internet
en tout cas qui se vantait avant
l'arrivée de de magnus aller le pion
lesetja emprise qui va peut-être en prie
le pion csii adam proches 4 matt
attention couvert par hikaru la dame qui
reculent dé 8 prises prise ça rentre
dans la finale mais c'est un peu un
scénario qu'on a vu dans ce match il car
nous qui à 14 secondes avance un plomb
de plus mais la position et peut-être
pas si dramatique pour alexandre mais
olexandre est si la tour à deux tours
tours à huit a pas le temps ça va faire
r ça va faire 15h15 ou qui s'envole dans
ce premier set
ça doit être dur dans la tête pour
alexandre l'a peut-être ce qu'il faut
faire c'est juste un peu tenté son
va-tout peut-être un c'est pas un fou
price est lui envoie une méthode ruiz en
plus et essayer de bien se mettre pour
le deuxième set de bien démarrer le
deuxième set parce que ça fait râler il
faut se lâcher faut se détendre il faut
vraiment rentré dans le match allait
peut-être un petit d'amd de g4 nom joue
tranquille hikaru qui ait changé mais le
plus en d5 c'est bien joué
il n'a plus la donne et la paire de fou
mais il est bloqué deux pions sur case
blanche surtout au centre
vicat rookie qui jouent vraiment bien il
est fort il est fort il est fort
l'américain aller
ça a été éduquée qui va nuançant ses 4,5
ça va donner le pion à qui va peut-être
parties à aller porter qui peut
peut-être mettre une attaque sur le roi
ici pour une fois c'est lui qui a tout
les tous tout le jeu là allez faut qu'il
trouve quelque chose il va peut-être
ramener le fou jusqu'au 11/7 il est bien
autant dans cette partie
c'est pas mon avis c'est important pour
la confiance de la gagner mais caroux
qui récupère les pions hikaru qui fait
et il n'ya pas fou price is et enfin
deux variantes aller ça se passe pas si
mal
il peut pas prendre des katas tour
contre sept il prend 1,7 et hikaru qui
son sort il a plus de vies qu'un chat
c'est un chat hikaru est un chat
incroyable trois pions pour la qualité
et c'est de nouveau un massage cardiaque
en fait une erreur il a filé un pion
mais là ça là il va la jouer ça là il va
la jouer dix secondes de plus une
position difficile pour bordeaux mais
qu'importe et qui réussit encaissé le
pion g café qui tient là nul aller
bortnik qui retarde l'échéance ça peut
lui donner la confiance donc ni qui
réussit un peu mieux dans cette
ouverture a et ça peut ça peut le faire
ça peut le faire pour le joueur
ukrainien mais là il a redonné une pièce
sur fois aussi ça y avait des 5
quoique il récupère en d2 ça il a eu un
peu de réussite mais bon il finit avec
un pion - mais ya pas qu un pion - il ya
un pion et 13 secondes
il a vraiment du mal à jouer vite en
début de partie à il va pouvoir mettre
sa touche f5
allez c'est peut-être pas mal là pour
bortnik enfin pas mal n'a pas mal joué
la tour de hikaru qui va partir en g5
tombé 5 qui tombait à tour pranger 2
savard faire nul à lille a bien tenu à
les porter qui semble enfin rentrer dans
le match
il est enfin rentré dans le match le
jeune ukrainien avait gagné la première
partie histoire deux histoires deux
allées localement des trois terrains
petite dame 2 alors ça va partir de 22h
5dans berticot et qui est pas mal et une
nouvelle fois c'est bien ce qui fait il
a pris confiance
hikaru qu est moins facile depuis trois
quatre parties ouais bien joué il kaouk
est dans le dur web orthez qui revient
bien là c'est beau c'est bien ce qui
fait il ya combien il prend h7 et voit
la première victoire de bortnik qui
recolle un petit peu et je vous aide il
est rentré dans le match
il est rentré dans le match l'ukrainien
et il marque
il marque le 1er point marque son
premier but ça va faire du bien dans la
tête alors on va voir ce qui va se
passer
est-ce que carbo va resserrer la vis ou
est ce que est ce que c'est un match
plus équilibré prévu auquel nous allons
assister
honnêtement bortnik qui a montré des
belles choses depuis trois quatre
parties toujours un peu derrière au
temps mais bon
ou plus résistants commence avec un
petit peu à s'habituer à son adversaire
alors on va voir est-ce que c'est hikaru
qui avait un peu desserré l'étau
possible à l'écart ou dans cette partie
qui est choquant c'est sa c5 menace rien
merci à tokyo qui s'adonnait avec avec
switch prime alors rappelons que bord
qui avait éliminé maxime vachier lagrave
au tour précédent alors le fou qui se
fait un petit peu chassés mais le pion à
poux b2 qui peut le garder non il prend
aux ja tour 8 pouces et 5 et il n'aura
pas le temps de choper le pion à et la
finale de foot couleurs opposées duras
et hikaru lakiha qui en a remis un petit
peu et le roi qui va se balader sur
cases noires et qui va venir
tranquillement
il va pas y arriver mais il va tenter de
devenir maître le roi noir dans un
réseau est maintenant il ya les pions
parce équipe a acquis qui s'embrase qui
s'en voit bien de l'autre côté fo f3
échec non échec échec et tour de ré
c'était c'était difficile hikaru qui en
a remis une petite 5 1 balle de set pour
hikaru nakamura alexandre bortnikov
service mais écart ou qui peut le
briquet et prendre le set ce qui lui
permettrait de démarrer le deuxième set
avec les pièces blanches salua heroes 26
52 dans le chatt oubliez pas que vous
voulez follow la chaîne chaise comme
pour retrouver tout le contenu
à l'ennemi de la qui gagne encore un
pion il peut malheureusement pas prendre
b6 pascal fou emprise est une nouvelle
fois il paye un peu c'est petit temps
d'arrêt là il manque un poil de vitesse
dans le milieu de jeu il caron qui qui
est tout simplement plus rapide encore
quinze secondes avance et à tous qui
tombe pour bortnik tour d2 il ya
cavalier e 4 la dame n'arrive en quatre
menaces m'attend nains menaces le fou ça
va faire si ça n'a tout en prise à ça va
vite ça va vite avec hikaru icaew qui
remporte le premier set 6 jeux à 1
bien joué bien jouer hikaru bortnik qui
est quand même a le mérite d'avoir un
peu résisté mais c'est vrai que ça
rappelle un peu un peu des matchs de
nadal à roland garros dès qu'il a pu un
peu sur l'accélérateur
rien ne semble résister à son coup droit
lifté repart pour le deuxième set
apparemment pas vraiment de pause ça
enchaîne ça enchaîne allait enfin gardé
un fauve savait des choses importantes
annoncées on est pour le moment à 0 0
dans ce deuxième set
et ce serait bien pour le ser les
fourrages trois font envoyer à l'essai
bien jouer olexandre voilà c'est ça
qu'on veut voir aller la foia les
cavaliers 4 tu t'en fous tu en vois tu
envoies a été obligée à lille va prendre
4 il va pas franchement ça car ailier g4
fou prend qui on prend et jouer tous
réussissent mais sa part à un manque un
temps il marque un gros temps d'arrêt il
a su et il a su aimer joue peut-être un
bon coup tour des huit avec l'idée de
jouer tour des cinq tours g5 f4 de la
partie car où il peut prendre le père
pète déjà
pour la gagne il a raison ouais c'est
bien joué ça allait tendre son va-tout
n'ai pas de père pète pas deux nuls
peut-être obligé de la prendre la vérité
chi su aller mais c'est ça qu'on veut
voir bortnik qui hier bien envoyé il
faut absolument qu'ils s'en prennent aux
rois d'hikaru c'est vraiment sa seule
chance c'est vraiment la seule chance
non je trouve vraiment que ce format
pour revenir un peu ce qui se dit dans
le chat je trouve vraiment que c'est le
bon format pour pour savoir qui est le
meilleur c'est un format qui est bien
bien plus exigeant et qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de chance entre guillemets que
dans les arénas
je trouve que les échecs c'est quand
même une compétition pour être plus fort
que les autres il faut du a zappé il
faut du 1 v1 c'est c'est là qu'on peut
vraiment jauger le niveau des joueurs
c'est un peu comme d'ailleurs dans l'est
sur ta du monde deux partis classiques
acquis étrangers 4 portes et qui gagne
pièce c'est plus difficile ce serait
moins - juste de voir un tournoi comme
les candidats ou quoi pour décerner le
titre de champion du monde parce qu'on
voit vraiment bien dans une
confrontation comme celle là qui est le
plus fort qui est le patron et
d'ailleurs c'est magnus qui était le
patron dans les speed class 1 qui était
meilleur dans tout les cadences donc un
avis sans aucun doute dans ce format
aussi mais c'est vraiment le format le
plus approprié pour décerner un titre à
les portes nikki mène 1-0 dans ce set
il peut confirmer franchement et sur ce
qu'il a montré en fin de en fin de
premier set c'était mieux
hikaru qui est un peu en danger si lent
mais une deuxième il peut égaliser
allait peut-être un coup comme cinq
bornes icna qui est bien depuis quelques
parties
alors ça reste un petit peu ça reste
chaud ici hein mais il est quand même
mieux
autant il a moins de retard que dans les
parties précédentes
maintenant il va falloir s'accrocher pas
s'en faire coller une petite parce que
là il ya ton propre cette fronde et 5
qui arrive et il va se faire mater
c'est dommage parce qu'il a il essaie de
se taper
il essaye de jouer plus vite ils
essayent de se mettre à niveau et il a
fait dam des huit dates le meilleur coup
mais c'est dur il ya beaucoup de menaces
menace de prendre cette prendre prendre
des cinq sa part il va prendre des 5000
y aura peut-être le clouage delà de la
vallée faut prendre tempo il n'y a pas
le choix de toute façon pour bortnik
faut jouer pour voyager cette année faut
accélérer à l'écart ou qui joue
superbement bien d'un prendrait cette
dame prend 1,5 d'un projet 7 vous prend
à 8 mai bortnik qui trouve peut-être une
défense
aya plus d'échecs à aimer les seuils
tant d'autres choses dans ce set bartoli
qui tentent d'accélérer un petit peu
temps d'accélérer un petit peu
allez bortnik là qu'il ya de nouveau
avec les blancs en tout cas il ya du
mieux
ouais c'est bien c'est bien joué ça
olexandre qui prend sa chance il agrée
sicav ou sans arrêt alors peut-être ça
passera pas tout le temps mais s'il veut
faire un résultat ça passe par là et
espérait qu' une tactique derrière là
pour le moment il ya une pièce de plus
mais s'il trouve rien c'est fini cas où
qui va faire le dos rond qui va remettre
ses pièces et ce sera perdu il essaye de
faire d'eux de faire le tour mais là il
caron qui réussit à se mettre en
position position foetale de défense il
va garder sa pièce il va l'emporter mais
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça que
bortnik a réussi à faire des points sans
juin voilà plus agressif en envoyant à
fond mais là il lui reste plus de pièces
malheureusement il n'ya qu'un échec au
f5 roi g7 et c'est fini mais allez je
pense que c'est si s'il veut renverser
la table ce sera comme ça allez il faut
continuer il faut continuer comme ça
prend l'initiative
il faut prendre l'initiative y allez
allez fouiller catway il faut il faut
tenter il faut tenter son va tout au
moins un petit peu déstabilisé hikaru
pas avoir l'impression d'avoir d'avoir
pris une cartouche et seuil minimal de
mettre un petit peu sous pression
allez la tour qui va partir à est le
foot est roi fou prend b3 assez bien
joué il a gagné un pion peut-être hikaru
peut se sentir alors pas mal à l'aise
parce qu'il est bien au dessus mais en
attaquant comme il le fait ça ça peut
faire réfléchir hikaru qui peut vouloir
assurer un petit peu mon avis ça passe
vraiment par là à l'est d'alger d'un
médecin qui va peut-être prendre
sk ya le pion à qui file à haut risque à
5h 4h 3h 4 ya pas tourbe et de r il ya
le pion qui file en a huit
hikaru qui est safe
karoutchi issife way down des huit
échecs seigneur jouer il va prendre
prendre ces 5 et une nouvelle fois non
seulement la position est gagnante mais
en plus il ya là avance à la pendule
pour icare ou alors ça fait 3 3 jeux à 1
hikaru qui fait mal hein hikaru qui fait
man premier set et eu 6 1 il ya 3 1 dans
le deuxième
alors une nouvelle fois un beau retenu
qui a placé un pion h6 j'aime bien
j'aime bien ce qui fait je pense que si
il n'a rien à se reprocher dans le
contenu un lay avait tour des huit
matches s'ils prenaient en des huit donc
une nouvelle fois il est gagnant c'est
vraiment depuis qu'il a acquis la fait
un peu ce ce cet ajustement
cet ajustement qui réussit à à faire
mieux aller il ya 3 2 il est distancé
dans ce set mais on sent qu'il a qu'il a
trouvé leur pas l'antidote aikau à la
morsure de duke obodo écart ou fait mal
il a pas l'antidote mais au moins il y
là il a trouvé le style de jeu qui peut
lui permettre de mettre en danger on
voit là une nouvelle fois qu'il essaye
un maximum d'envoyer à l'est le roi
alors après ça va devenir un peu un peu
prévisible mais am dam des trois c'est
bien joué et on prend trois
intermédiaires fois ci ce bon sens et
caro qui veut un peu sécurisé qui veux
pas tu veux plus prendre ces attaques de
roy est ce que ça peut le faire déjouer
on sais pas peut-être il peut un petit
peu déjoué allez on va peut-être mettre
un pion aux six mètres un pion à 6
on tient les cases blanches si
lecavalier réussissez à venir en d5 ce
serait génial il y avait les pions qui
tenait sa part qu'adp mettons g7
pourquoi un set ça va être fort parce
qu'il ya le fou en b2 tapis dans l'ombre
et g6 et g7 et ça file à dam
c'est dommage c'est dommage
là encore il y avait peut-être quelque
chose à faire il ya 4 2 il renvoie une
calloc'h et c'est bien ce qu'il fait
c'est vraiment bien
on avait vu et vécu une partie un petit
peu comme ça dans le premier set mais
payant f3 cette fois ci car ou qui a
mieux géré par le premier set s'il avait
été un peu dans le mal un peu dans le
dur dans cette variante mais ça semble
être mieux se passer pour lui dans cette
partie est née carven qui revient vers
ses 5 qui va réussir à ouvrir le jeu à
cavaliers pros f2 à ça fait mal parce
que les bleus n'ont plus qu'une tour et
pour attaquer sur les colonnes ouverte
on en a besoin il ya 25 secondes de
retard
ça prend mandéens ça va prendre j'ai
trois ou six tours f8 tour f2 c'est un
massacre
rmc que si tu prends g7
il ya bien trop de retard matériellement
il ya de qualité de - bosnie qui avait
trouvé des petites arnaques dans les
matches précédents la tour va venir en
effet suite à mon avis n'ont même pas à
ils se replacent if échec
ça fait 5 2 ça défile ça défile
allez encore une partie dans ce deuxième
set pour le moment hikaru qui mène 5-2 à
2025 jose ailleurs voir dans le tchat
il souffre pornic mais moi je trouve qu'
il tente sa chance à fond le problème
c'est que là il reprend une fourchette
ils essaient d'accélérer il fait ce qui
peut la modifier son style de jeu il
tente un peu ce qui tend un peu tout ce
qui peut et la d3 qui marchent pas le
problème c'est quand il accélère il se
prend des tactiques quand il ralentit
hyper autant là il est un peu d'activité
de nouveau mais caroux qui réussit à
tout couvrir les prend b3 tout repenser
cette ouais mais a non seulement il va
faire des quatre il ya dix secondes de
moins autant il ya une pièce de moins
haut il fait monter la tactique un
relief si ça c'est beau il y avait je
vous le redis qu'il a joués sur le cloud
halle et cavaliers six échecs sur dame
prend iliad 1.8 et suroît g7 avec les
pros hutte où n'importe quel coup droit
qui prend 8 ça fait 6 2 6 1 6 2 on est
un peu cru en début de deuxième set il a
un peu remonté et de nouveau y ce il a
la tête au fond des chiottes
il allait la tête au fond des toilettes
del pueblo là ça va être difficile
ça va être difficile là il est vraiment
dans le dur
dans le très dur même écart ou qui est
bon le seul joueur à avoir inquiété
hikaru finalement c'était fil rouge à je
pense que dans ce tableau il y avait que
fil rouge à qui pouvait lui prendre un
set
l'ornement cmv elle a déjà joué où il a
déjà gagné son match pour la troisième
place florent flore karoutchi qui aurait
pu perdre contre eux qui auraient pu
perdre contre contre firoud déjà c'est
la pause c'est financé la pose sans
trois sets gagnants
donc c'est la pause ensuite on aura
et ensuite on aura un dernier un dernier
set
en espérant qu'on a un peu de spectacle
dans ce dernier set que pour le moment
c'est un petit peu à sens unique
rina ronis qui semblait pouvoir tenir
n'a car wayne à roddy ce qu'ils firent
ouja ce sont des joueurs quand même un
peu plus fort que porte ni car mon avis
en bullet alors on en dira combien pour
l'instant deux sets zéro magnetico de
7,0 pour hikaru 6-1 6-2 et mvl qui a
gagné le premier match gagné trois
matches et un gain du match pour la
troisième place le premier match de la
journée
il a qu'à la chirurgie alors je sais
plus si la saison 17 ans maintenant mais
il est très jeune
ce qui est donc très impressionnant et
bien évidemment il est très précoce il
pourrait être champion du monde un jour
deux parties en en cadence longue moment
ça repart pas encore mis d'accord il a
il a au moins 16 ans je pense que je
peux je peux regarder un bon soir à
française man t'inquiète pas ça va bien
se passer olexandre bien se passer de
t'inquiète pas
c'est vraiment un massacre
alors gens pressés de chéquiers le truc
sur jamais c'est reparti alors hikaru à
l'écart ou troisième set
les fonds et collection la nounou galles
une ou deux parties d'entrer y avait
peut-être aussi sur cahier des cinq
d'ailleurs annoncé qu'il prend des
quatre niveaux bortnik l'armée qui est
déjà pas forcément très rare il faut que
vos shows pella calloc'h il fallait la
prendre cette qualité non y vas pas va
rester en prise et finit par l'apprendre
et karaoké à prendre prendre des cinq
noms il a perdu 15 secondes qui repart
un peu sur la stratégie du premier set
c'est à dire enfin je passais dans une
stratégie si c'est voulu mais jouer un
high adam français 4 à l'écart ou qui
craque un peu tient peut-être un peu
trop facile ça lui permet de mettre
peut-être le premier jeu à bortnik il
aura l'avantagé au moins dans le set
allez allez olexandre faut vraiment
qu'ils la gagnent c'est là à tourcoing
f4 je pense on supprime le cavalier la
trombe et ok ça va tomber trois lacs à
les protéger encore la dame
bon là ça devrait ça devrait passer une
tour de plus
même s'il a un peu mal autant il nous a
déjà prouvé
ouais ouais c'est bien joué ça iran iran
un peu de matos et cavaliers qui va
venir mais alors que va faire et karl
[Musique]
c'est pas très bien joué de la part du
caroux quoique allait bien fait bortnik
il remporte la première partie du set
aller 1-0 dans ce set
ça démarre bien à l'essai c'est là que
sa part faut capitaliser là dessus pour
bortnik il faut capitaliser là dessus
pour botanique histoire histoire
d'espérer dans ce match aller pour le
mans il ya 4 0 a poussé cette ça fait
mal
ah il fait mal ce fou c'est 7 mais bon
c'est pas fini fini il ya du jeu alain
le roy a laissé la stratégie qui avait
permis à bord nique de de faire un peu
quelque chose là d'attaquer là le roi
fonds à elf ou d3 bien joué et
foucambert les récupère une calloc'h il
atteint calais cette finale a et un plan
b si ce qui va tomber c'est dommage a
pas le temps de faire payer 17 et donc
la finale est juste égal mais il ya
quinze secondes de plus pour hikaru qui
à mon avis en plus mené au score va
tenter le tout pour le tout
c'est à dire de faire tomber ou de flag
et si on veut utiliser du jargon bull et
est allé yahoo qui pas mal rires oui
mais bon il est bon parce que il
il y joue la pendule un jeu où la
pendule un bien les pions sur
l'échiquier un maximum de temps il est
bon parce qu'ils influent plus et que et
qu'en plus près les nuls ça la mélisse
avec en premier ni terres ou qui
égalisera m elle était nue je pense à la
fin je mange déjà fait cette finale là
on courait fallait je pense qu numérique
celui avec cellules mais je suis même
pas sûr la partie qui encore pas mal la
danse ouverture c'est pas mal ce qui
fait c'est pas mal ce qui fait bortnik
il se bat bien une bonne foi et karaoké
mal à la sortie de l'ouverture c'est
incroyable parce que great choucas perdu
contre bortnik en ayant des supers
d'ouverture et hikaru qui prend même les
ouvertures un peu à la légère et qui
réussit à être être loin devant c'est
juste pour un peu montrer le talent du
bonhomme
voilà pas d ouverture pourri non plus un
mais juste il a pas il prend pas du coup
davantage en ouverture et malgré ça ils
malgré ça il est devant à l'est de
pornic qui
et peut-être pas si mal le roi qui va
revenir aux deux en d2 c'est bien joué
contre le pion d'abord est c'est bien
joué de la part du caroux à les coupes
mais ils m'appelleront eux deux ok to re
4,4 g 4 le roi qu'il y en a six ok
menace maths mais le roi le roi qui va
repartir il va sacrifier la tour et les
pions qui vont gagner les pions qui vont
gagner la turquie ayant af23 b5 aux ja
touret six tours h6 bien jouer bortnik
oh le contre et chacun des 4 as il avait
défendu comme un beau diable mais pareil
toujours pareil lui manque un peu de
temps elle fait mal celle là il était
bien bortnik y jouait bien il fait pas
des mauvaises parties dans le contenu il
est pas mal hein on voit la caméra qu'il
n'en peut plus il rougit bortnik il a
rougi rivas tués quoique c'est une photo
ou pas ou c'est non c'est la caméra mais
issue on voit qui sut pourra qu'aider
devenant issue issue complètement
il est bon il est pourri car oui les
bons laïcards occupe peut-être pas celle
à démultiplier 1
il ya 2 1 il a peut-être très envie de
danse finir masse cavalière 5 mètres le
pion g4 est allé c'est pas si mal
bortnik qui a pas mal joué il a réussi à
passer le front des cats la tour eiffe
cassilas gagnant cavalli ossètes ay ay
ay ay ay la dame
oh la la
la finit par se re faire planter ça va
trop vite ça va trop vite pour alexandre
il joue trop bien et quart où il avait
fait une super série de coups étaient
bien revenus dans la partie et est
repassée même devant et il reprend
encore une tactique à l'e3 on a du mal à
y croire mais tout est toujours possible
pour qu'il y en ait cette attention ça
ça sent le ça sent le problème bortnik
qui se remet déjà mal autant sous la
pression à une sacrifie la caboche
il a déjà une qualité de moins et caro
qui a fait ef à la vitesse de la lumière
qui a été très bien joué
quel niveau ils ont ses joueurs quand
même hein c'est stratosphérique un la d3
d4 est fou prend des 4 et la dame est
cloué la performance du karoun
stratosphérique intouchable intouchable
hikaru au dessus simplement au dessus du
game simplement au dessus du game j'ai
l'impression que vraiment mis à part
mise à part firoud déjà et ça remet
aussi en perspective l'énorme
performance de firouz gars qui s'était
qualifié dès le premier tournoi et qui
avait mis caron un sacré difficulté ils
menaient ils menaient 7 à 5,1 le jeune
ali reza dans le match et finalement il
car on était remonté en finissant sur un
4 sur 4
magistral mais il aurait pu perdre dès
le premier tour
premier tour piège qui avait finalement
eu des allures de finale vraiment bon ce
n'est qu'avec une pièce en option -
parlant une nouvelle fois hyper hyper un
deuxième pion il a un purement et 20
secondes de moins mais là la différence
de niveau est incroyable c'est
impressionnant
c'est tout bonnement impressionnant il
harcèle le fou bon moment il fait les
petites menaces au bon moment il se
rétracte au bon moment il revient avec
le cavalier de l'autre côté il revient
vers la casaque 4 qu'il faut avoir
soufflé sur échec ayant encore une
qualité qui tombe c'est une
démonstration
c'est une humiliation alors attention on
aimerait tous se faire humilier par
hikaru parce que c'est beau ce café
bortnik dans ce tournoi il a éliminé
quand même coup sur coup alexandre
alexander great chioukhs et maxime
vachier lagrave donc bortnik attention
on veut pas du tout minimiser sa
performance est un beau tournoi qui
réalise mais la face à hikaru la
différence de niveau est impressionnante
c'est vraiment comme nadal à roland tu
arrives en 2000 tu fais un gros roland
garros et tu prends et tu prends 6 1 6 2
6 1 alors que tu avais battu des mecs de
très haut niveau du top 10 mondial que
tu pensais être fort mais à un moment
donné par apa qui arrivent et tu peux
rien y faire c'est exactement ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui pour alexandre il leur
a pas rougir de sa performance sur le
tournoi mais mais simplement il tombe ce
soir sur un écart ou au dessus au dessus
de tout allez on va essayer quand même
de vivre un peu plus longtemps 5 1 il
faut il faut gagner pour survivre la
olexandre avec les pièces blanches mais
en at il envie hein en at il envie at il
envie de survivre seulement ou at il
envie de se laisser alors pas forcément
volontairement mais inconsciemment at il
envie de se laisser mourir à f/5 que
c'est bien joué
il joue sur le courage du pion aux cinq
hikaru qui est vraiment vraiment
vraiment dans une autre galaxie
il a un pion plus il va encore envoyé
sur leroy b 5 b 4 il s'en prend qui on
vous promet 4 est un petit ours et de
aux dames c'est un échec en premier la
tour qui tombe ça ne pouvait se terminer
que sur un nouveau cheapos une nouvelle
double attaque une nouvelle tour qui
tombe et hikaru 6 2 non 600cc 6
2 6 1 6 1 ou 6 1 6 2 6 1 massacre 45
minutes de jeu j'ai envie de dire
heureusement qu'on avait le format 7 une
nouvelle fois parce que voir une si
match a duré une heure et demie ça a été
long les 45 dernières minutes parce que
c'était une boucherie massacre à la
tronçonneuse extraordinaire hikaru
vraiment très très très fort on
s'attendait à une performance de cet
acabit mais il confirme il confirme une
nouvelle fois écart ou quand bull est
mis à part
magnus qui semble être au dessus sur ce
qu'on a vu dans leur match et peut-être
quelques jeunes s'ils roulent déjà
spécialiste ou narrow dit skip sont
quand même des spécialistes de la
cadence même là un autre gros
spécialistes bortnik mais là ça suffit
pas pour avoir une chance contre hikaru
il semble qu'il ait que trois quatre
hommes dans le monde qui puissent qu'ils
puissent qu'ils puissent s'asseoir en
face de lui et lui dire je peux te
donner un match mais voilà c'est
impressionnant mais c'est beau c'est
beau à voir
après il faut des adversaires il faut il
faut organiser ce genre de tournoi pour
voir à quel point à quel point les
joueurs sont forts donc c'est c'est
intéressant d'avoir suivi ce match et
d'avoir pu jauger le niveau dit
carrément bull est pour pour avoir un
une comparaison possible pour voir ce
que ce que ça vaut mais c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment somptueux
je suis bien contente pas avoir joué
assez dur de jouer contre des joueurs de
ce niveau là quelle puissance quelle
force démonstrations
il est rapide il est bon
c'est vraiment un patron en patron il va
falloir vraiment voir un un magnus
carlsen ou en face on nous dit dans le
chat il avait pas grand chose à prouver
mais il fallait quand même être là il
fallait quand même être là et et montrer
qu'il était le meilleur et c'est ce
qu'il a fait donc n'hésitez pas
évidemment apollo la chaîne parce qu'il
va y avoir beaucoup d'événements cette
année avec des speechs s mais oui firoud
déjà au premier tour contre ma cassette
un peu dommage mais voilà c'était le
tirage au sort enfin la règle en a
décidé ainsi
j'ai 22 21h20 où ça finit quand même
assez tôt je remets un point sur les
règles pour que vous comprenez bien
pourquoi le match est fini
et pourquoi il a été remporté par icare
ou trois sets gagnants les trois sets
ont été gagnés en cinq sets premier à
3,7 gagne hikaru qui a remporté les
trois sets ça commence comme speech à
sari rose à commencer par le speech s
junior enfin fin avril début mai il n'y
a pas encore de date officielle mais ça
a commencé là dans quelques semaines
pour le meilleur américain de l'histoire
c'est probablement bobby fischer on peut
aussi penser apple morphy maka qui est
forcément impressionnant qui est l'un
des tout meilleurs joueurs américains de
tous les temps mais quand même on peut
pas le mettre sur un pied d'égalité avec
murphy ou fischer il faudrait au moins
avoir un titre de champion du monde pour
en partie donc pour pour pouvoir espérer
avoir un avoir ce nom
qu'est-ce que vous avez des petites
questions ce qu'il ya des choses sur
lesquelles vous voulez revenir
vous pouvez aussi aller voir les
interviews officielles bien évidemment
sur twitch point tv slash chess pour
aider à éventuellement faire un raid si
vous voulez aller suivre les interviews
match était vraiment intéressant je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez
il ya un grand merci à monsieur pessoa
qui mit un immense merci kiev pour avoir
suivi tous cet événement alors oui je
vais en profiter aussi pour remercier de
chasse comme parce que c'est un
événement officiel casque sommes donc là
pour la peine
j'en profite pour le dire parce que
c'est très sympa de leur part c'est un
événement qui était rémunéré au
commentaire que ce soit pour mathieu
cornette ou pour moi même donc un grand
merci à jesse comme d'avoir fait appel à
moi pour commenter cet événement qui
était un bel événement qui était
vraiment joli sympa à suivre est donc un
grand merci à thiès comme d'avoir et
organiser l'événement et vous avoir
proposé des commentaires officiels en
france est donc vraiment un grand merci
à eux
donc j'en profite pour les remercier
mouais les quarts de finale étaient plus
intenses ed sasso sega est vrai c'est
comme ça mais c'était sympa scène
choisit la soirée finita d'art oui mais
si on aura une nouvelle soirée de demain
soir du coup avec la finale des arénas
je vous promets rien de d'exceptionnel
mais mais bon on essaiera de faire ce
qu'on peu après c'est dur lâche sort de
d'une semaine avec sept jours de stream
d'affilée ce sera le huitième c'est un
peu dur et beaucoup d'énergie
aujourd'hui et je vais faire une petite
mais petit merguez vegan c'est quoi la
firme les arénas sera sur la chaîne
bitstream c'est le dernier dernier droit
de la saison mais les commentaires
étaient plus nerveux progrès et j'espère
que ça vous a plu
j'essaye de vous faire vivre le truc à
fond
j'essaie de faire vivre le truc à fond
ok merci à toi que ni chasse comme
n'aurait pas trouvé mieux que toi pour
les commentaires c'est sympa web en fait
caisse comme qui me permet de continuer
à faire à faire vis ma chaîne bitstream
en me permettant de commenter des
événements comme celui-là et de et de me
faire gagner un petit peu d'argent donc
c'est vraiment très cool de leur part
parce que sans eux on pourrait pas avoir
non plus les vidéos à côté si tu vois
c'est que ça permet de ça me permet de
financer ce que je fais à côté donc
c'est sympa mais oui à mais d'un autre
côté le critère de chasse comme pour
prendre les gens restent toujours les
des critères assez juste d'ailleurs ce
cas c'est sympa les audiences le nombre
d'abonnés le travail fait sur youtube
c'est pas forcément le cas de tous les
sites où deux ou deux tout le monde donc
c'est sympa de faire profiter de faire
profiter quand il ya un petit peu
d'argent bas des gens qui je vais parler
pour moi donc c'est un peu difficile
d'être juge et partie mais qu'ils le
méritent entre guillemets c'est toujours
plaisir de voir des gens qui ont des
chaînes qui s'investissent et tout ça
quoi alors à chaque ticket mais non fils
andré à regarder une vidéo avec moi une
partie était lancée dans une punchline
pinip unis j'étais punie mon fils était
mort de rire depuis je veux regarder
apprendre à jouer là bas c'est cool on a
mangé se disent de cette semaine du
bullet comme jamais ouais on est sapé
comme jamais fais du pilates comme
jamais
il veut punir mais il faut toujours
finir survivre et punir chaque jour où
tu survis ça ne peut que servir qu'à
punir
ok donc du coup aussi follow et enfin
follow la tchèque la chaîne tchèque
czech com fr ça peut être que bien pour
avoir plus de commentaires en français à
venir donc c'est assez important pour
nous et on voit du contenu en français
tout ça c'est sympa aussi de deux joué
le jeu et 2 et 2 mètres et de mettre un
petit follow quoi ça fait pas de mal
un petit sou pour conclure voilà on va
peut-être qu'on va mettre un petit é
irissou pour conclure et qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire on peut faire un raid sur la
chaîne officielle et puis on voit ce qui
se passe c'est parce qu'il va y avoir
comme ceux comme comme stream
donc je m'arrête sur la chaîne
officielle parce que je sais pas quoi
faire et on se retrouve demain soir à
21h pour la rime je peux pas inscrits
mais une petite heure aujourd'hui tu me
fais un peu de blitz non en échec 9 69
enfin là cette semaine on est déjà sûr
du 17 18 heures de stream des vidéos il
ya 1 re stream demain on va un petit peu
on va un petit peu récupéré à link petit
raid je l'espère la soirée et on se
retrouve demain soir 21h
merci à tous ciao ciao et sur les
grenouilles a discuté il ya toujours le
disque ans